so
members take their seats
here why don't you get in line
good
members take their seats
oh
uh
the house will come to order
the members will be attended through
announcements from the clerk
good morning members of the house please
take your seats if you have not already
done so we have a couple of quick
announcements please
first and foremost if you've ever been
to this type of place you need to
understand about validating your parking
there is a validating stamp
at both the democratic and republican
sides of the chamber
if you believe that your stamp has been
uh
has been
if you believe that your ticket has
already been validated but it does not
say client paid on the stamp then you
must get it stamped at the party tables
bathrooms
over to my left
are masked restrooms only
right outside the door over here to my
right
are unmasked restrooms please follow the
signs thank you
uh when you are speaking today
please identify which microphone you're
speaking at and please state your name
so that we know for the journal who
you're who you are thank you very much
the house will come to order
the recess session of june 24 2021 is
now reconvened and i declare a quorum is
present the house will attend to a
prayer by house chaplain reverend bob
stewart pastor of saint paul's united
methodist church in manchester
good morning and happy new year to all
of you
i'd like to begin sharing a short prayer
for the new year written by rabbi evan
mafik
eternal god
you gave us the greatest gift
the gift of life
in the coming year
help us use it wisely
may we grow in generosity
kindness and forgiveness
may we grow in hope
faith
and love
amen
tender and compassionate god
we seek to know you through the reading
and hearing of your word and pray that
we may go beyond hearing to obey
as shown by your
by the faithful life of your departed
servant representative barbara shaw
whom we honor and remember this day
she served you and the great state of
new hampshire for the past 22 years
we know that barbara was special in your
eyes
worthy of your special attention and
ours
for she served you and us well
in the tasks that were given to her
o god of both the living and the dead
we praise your holy name for all your
servants
who have faithfully lived and died
we thank you for the sacred ties that
bind each of us together to those unseen
who encompass us as a cloud of witnesses
we have been encouraged by barbara
and her example of leadership
through her example of love
for others
o loving and compassionate god we pray
for barbara's friends and her family as
they grieve her passing
god of us all your love never ends
when all else fails you still
are god
we pray to you for one another in our
need
and for all anywhere who mourn with us
this day
let us pause for a moment of silence as
we remember our colleague
our friend and our sister
barbara e shaw
who went home to the lord on wednesday
december 22nd
oh god to us you have entrusted the task
of governing this state
the state of new hampshire
make us faithful in our service
in our discussions for this new year
give us clarity and understanding of
differing views
let us listen to each other
so that we may have a clear picture of
the matters at hand
in our voting give us wisdom and
integrity
be with each of us this day as we make
decisions for all those that we
represent
may our voice be a voice
that is pleasing to your ears oh god
be with us and guide us through this day
we pray amen
mr speaker it's my understanding that
the remarks of the chaplain are always
placed in the permanent journal
therefore there's no reason to ask for
the memorialization of representative
shaw to be put in the perimeter
record because that is done
automatically
the chair recognizes the member from
londonderry representing albel disarro
who will lead us in a pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
please remain standing for the plane of
our national anthem
[Music]
so
[Applause]
the house will attend to request
oh
the house will attend to request release
of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives aldrich dauntonville
fenton hopper litchfield pantalakas
rhodes royal spain van de castille
the day important business
representatives birch cody ebel fargo
moran milor salloway southworth the day
illness and the family sandler savakidis
tanner
these leaves of absence will be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will now attend to
communication
mr speaker in a letter dated july 22nd
mr speaker please accept my resignation
from the house of representatives
effective immediately enclosed are my
key cards my transponder and a key that
janet claimant will need to lob offices
sincerely lynn ober
july 22nd 2021 mr speaker please accept
my resignation from the house of
representatives effective immediately
and closed our my key card and my
transponder sincerely russell t ober iii
july 29 2021 good evening mr speaker mr
clerk my apologies for not having
notified you sooner of my recent move
out of hillsborough 6 goffstown shortly
after the closing on my goffstown home i
drafted an email on my ipad while
traveling and for some reason the email
did not send from that device please
accept this email as my formal
resignation to the new hampshire house
of representatives it's been an absolute
honor and pleasure to serve alongside
the members of the people's house from
the first day i walked up the steps of
the state house to my last it's been a
humbling experience and one i will
forever cherish
my resignation has been brought on by
business opportunity which involves
relocating my family to the state of
florida where i will be starting and
managing a new joint venture between
myself and italian manufacturer
i am forever grateful that my
constituents in goffstown entrusted me
with the duties of legislating for their
community but the difficult decision to
relocate was best for my family
although i will now be residing in
florida i will always be a new hampshire
right i will tru truly miss my time in
the house and i'm hoping that someday i
will have another opportunity to serve
best regards michael
gunski october 27
20 and 21
mr packard on september 17th i lost my
19 year old son andre denis dostie in a
motorcycle accident my son was my life
my love my everything i have a good
support system and i believe everything
will be all right i'm resigning as a new
hampshire state rep thank you for your
understanding thank you donald dusty
november 15 2021.
dear speaker packard as a friday
november 12th i no longer reside in
hillsboro district 3. i have moved to
londonderry which i believe is your
district
according to my understanding of house
rules i must resign my seat in the new
hampshire house i will miss the many
wraps reps and staff members who work so
hard to make the house a successful and
effective organization
i have appreciated all the effort that
goes into preserving the traditions and
dignity of our state government you have
my best wishes for the upcoming session
sincerely daniel pickering
december 17 2021.
dear paul please accept this
correspondence as my letter of
resignation from the new hampshire house
effective immediately
i want to begin by expressing my
gratitude to those whom i've had the
honor to represent my colleagues and to
everyone who makes the work we do
possible i've thoroughly enjoyed the
opportunity to serve in this body
the new year offers a time of change and
transition much has changed for me
personally in this year the biggest and
happiest change has been the blessing
i've received in becoming engaged to be
buried because of this i have moved to
vermont to be with my fiance and to
focus on our endeavor
and lives together as a soon-to-be
married couple i wish you a happy and
prosperous new year the important work
continues respectfully submitted dennis
m ruprecht jr
october 13th dear paul please be advised
that the following representative elect
was sworn into office by the governor
and executive council on this day
hillsborough county district 7 catherine
a rombo bedford sincerely william m
gardner secretary of state
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
dear paul please be advised on november
10 2021 the following representative
elect was sworn into officer office by
the governor and executive council on
this day andrew manaval harrisville
sincerely william m gardner secretary of
state
welcome to
welcome to the new hampshire housework
[Applause]
and on december 22 2021 dear paul please
be advised that the phone representative
elect was sworn into office by the
governor and executive council on this
day rockingham district six jody nelson
derry sincerely william m gardner
secretary of state welcome to the new
hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on house bill 98 relative
to the date of the state primary
election
the question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's veto
shall house bill 98 become law
recognizes representative abramson
to speak for the override
uh i'm sorry mr speaker i cannot find a
chair anywhere on the side in this
section
all right i'll find a chair afterwards i
didn't mean to bring that up now
thank you mr speaker i'm at oh there's a
chair right there
i'm asking members to vote green
in spite of the governor's veto on hb 98
we've been trying for many years to move
the state primary up even a month
and
this is
house bill 98 was the opportunity to do
that
the vast majority of
republicans and i would say every
republican i know on this side has
supported this bill
the idea was was simply that when we
talked to the secretary of state every
few years we have a time period
where
the september state primary will happen
just eight weeks before the general
election
and for some of our overseas military
personnel
and merchant mariners
they're not able to get their overseas
ballot to them
uh from the state primary and get it
back in time so this is simply about our
overseas
military people being able to uh be sure
that they get a vote we found that uh
it's a few hundred votes a year that end
up not getting counted and those are the
people who are overseas uh fighting for
our right to vote and so i i believe
that this bill is necessary
the member has a question uh yeah mr
speaker um would it be an order at this
point to move for a test vote to test
the clickers
or has that been done
here i would just
the clerk's informed me that they'll
replace the batteries in every single
clicker
and um they should work let's we have
they have tested it
you can test yours out by voting green
you need that
no that's taken private has never fallen
again
okay
good start for the day
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of members
present and voting is required to
override a veto
if you're in favor and the bill become
law you will press the green button if
you are opposed and wish to sustain the
governor's needle you will press the red
button
voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
representative bergeron
representative
cretien
representative de simone
representative emerick
representative faulkner
representative
bob green
representative griffith
representative hayward
representative kolansky
so
representatives
yes
um
representative alicea where are you
theresa
so
all right
have all members voted that were present
that had the ability to vote
house will attend to the state
to the state of the vote
38 voting yes
313 voting nay
the veto is sustained
and the test is complete
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on house bill 239 fn
relative to prosecutions for certain
assaults against minors the question
before the house is not withstanding the
governor's veto shall house bill 239 fn
become law
the chair recognizes representative
abramson
uh thank you mr speaker over here at d2
uh
this uh bill essentially was a attempt
to correct an error in the statute of
limitations
it was a result of
a constituent in my district his son
starting at age four
was
physically abused by his stepfather very
very badly something that continued for
many many years
by the time this was reported to the
police and was to be sent to the
county attorney's office to be
prosecuted
they were told that because the statute
of limitations of six years had run out
that there was simply no way that they
could prosecute
this particular case so
we found that there are many many child
abuse cases where the abuser and even
criminals who are attacking children are
getting off scot-free
by simply running out the clock the
six-year statute of limitations
so i took up this bill
in fact i ran for re-election in part to
put this bill in
and it was the simple intent was
that similar to sexual assault the clock
doesn't start running under this bill
until the victim turns age 18.
so the victim would have until they're
effectively 24 years old to report the
crime and go ahead and go after the uh
the child abuser or the attacker
now
at no point
uh during the process did anyone come
forward in either the state house or the
state senate and testify against this
bill in fact
the the bill this is the second time
through the bill had unanimous support
in the house criminal justice committee
had unanimous support on the floor it
had unanimous support in the senate
judiciary committee and in the floor of
the senate there was not a single member
of the general court who voted against
this
and i want to thank members for
supporting this bill
there was not
a single witness who came out and
testified and it wasn't until the veto
came in
that anyone had raised an objection
unfortunately i as the bill's sponsor
have not received any contact about
whatever whoever this mystery person is
from any of the ten county attorney's
offices or the
department of justice
out of hundreds of people possible i've
tried contacting the governor's
legislative liaison to find out who the
person is who raised an objection
to some technical issue about the bill
i've had other people including lawyers
remember the members of this house look
back at the bill and try to figure out
based on the veto message what the
problem is and
we can we can't guess here there's a
process that we maintain
in the state house
for public hearings that allow anyone in
the state to come forward and object if
they have a concern with a bill and no
one until after the bill had already
gone through stated anything and
absolutely no one has stated anything to
me i still i haven't gotten a word back
from the legislative liaison in three
years
um
so i'm i'm asking members to please
don't drag this on for another session
let's get this done now please press the
green button
and
don't let more child abusers and more
criminals get off scot-free by simply
abusing the statute of limitations let
people have a realistic chance to bring
their case forward and prosecute these
cases green button
chair recognizer representative abbas
thank you mr speaker over here at
d1
i rise in support of sustaining the
governor's veto
this bill is well intended and as the
previous speaker just said it passed on
consent last term and this term
however at the point where the
legislative process was completed there
were some concerns raised about some
unintended consequences
as part of the veto
they were nice enough to at least
provide some suggested language that
would accomplish the bill's objective
without these potential unattended
consequences
that language has been provided
and it's available on on the governor's
website
uh for that reason i think if
we work together in the committee we'll
be able to get this right and carry this
over the finish line so please push that
red button and support sustaining the
veto thank you
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of the members
president voting is required to override
a veto if you're in favor having the
bill become law you will press the green
button if you are opposed and wish to
sustain the governor's veto you will
press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
roll call
the problems
it is house bill 239 that we are voting
on right now
[Music]
uh
represent belanger representative
bernardi
mr clerk these screens are saying hb98
are we on hp no we're we're we're on
we're on house bill
i know i know we're under speakers
i know they're having a little problem
there having a technical issue they're
having a technical issue they're working
on it
representative o'brien
so
representative rambo are you here
can you push your clicker
has everyone president had a chance to
vote
house will state the vote
35 voting yay 312 vote in may
the governor's veto is sustained
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on house bill 242.
why does the member rise oh thank you
for recognizing mr speaker
i was this is uh related to the
confusion we had over the powerpoint we
have here is this
sessions being live stream and where can
people uh find the stream
yes and there's a link on the website
okay we're on the website
all right
we'll get that information for you all
right thank you thanks
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on house bill 242 relative
to the content of an adequate education
[Music]
right on the main page of the general
court site
if you click on
next house session that's where you'll
find the information
the question before the house not
withstanding governor's veto shall house
bill 242 become law the chair recognizes
representative luna
to speak for the override
thank you very much mr speaker
although house bill 2 242 was introduced
as a partisan bill
the final version of the bill from a
bipartisan committee of conference
report
included provisions that benefit
students like improvement in the
adequacy standard to include financial
literacy
and to benefit taxpayers
especially taxpayers who live in cities
and towns with lower property values
things that we can all agree on are good
for these reasons please support the
motion to let house bill 242 become law
thank you
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of the members
president of voting is required to
override a veto
the chair recognizes representative
mullen for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that there are many essential
parts to an adequate education and that
they must be demonstrated through both
knowledge and skill
and if i believe that curriculum areas
such as environmental sciences civics
and government
financial literacy and an understanding
of logic and rhetoric are key elements
among others
if i know that house bill 242 would
require that schools in new hampshire
are both transparent and accountable to
families and communities in providing
the specified components of an adequate
education
and that improvements made during the
committee of conference would benefit
economically disadvantaged students and
lessen the burden on taxpayers in
providing such an adequate education
would i now push the green yay button to
allow house bill 242 to become law
if you're in favor of having the bill
become law you will press the green
button if you are opposed and wish to
sustain the governor's veto you will
press the red button
voting stations are open
we're already we're already in the
voting mode representative i was put
down as a person to do a pi on this i
didn't have you on this one
unfortunately representative we didn't
have you on on the chart
loading stations were open for 30
seconds
representative adjutant representative
acton
representative huff
representative clee
representative lundgren
representative wiki representative
macbeth
representative mckinney
representative mirner
representative moran
representative norgren
representative
richards
representative snow
representative sykes
yes
so
if the members would please beg our
indulgence we are working on the
technical issue with the transcription
of the computer that's up here we're on
the phone with rit folks to try to
resolve it we apologize for any
confusion
have all members voted that had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
it's coming
165 voting yay 182 voting a the
governor's veto is sustained
the house will tend to the governor's
veto message on house bill 334
relative to prohibitions on carrying a
loaded firearm on an ohrv or snowmobile
relative to the procedure
for which conducting firearm background
checks
the question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's veto
shall house bill 334 become law the
chair recognizes
representative bert to speak
for the override
mr speaker while i am sitting here
if i may first
i can hear you but i cannot hear
whatever the clerk said in the previous
speeches he had
uh the microphone up here and not the
microphone but the speaker i can't hear
anybody
and the people around me are saying the
same thing so i'll get to my speech and
am i allowed can i have asked a question
of the chair
state your question
am i allowed to say governor
because i know we can't speak of the
other body but am i allowed in my speech
to say governor
the member really shouldn't reference
any any member
or any or
talk about
yeah we don't we don't get into
the uh
other side of the aisle the other side
of the wall or
the the executive branch okay so thank
you i would appreciate it if you didn't
get into that
yep i'll
i won't say the word
thank you mr speaker
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker house bill 334 is a great
bill
the person that vetoed it hurt my
feelings
house bill 334 is a very simple simple
bill
what it allows
is for me
or anybody else in new hampshire to
carry a loaded handgun only a handgun
on a snowmobile or atv
that's all it does
why this bill was brought forward
was because fish and game has a law
that
goes against constitutional carry
and
i'm being told it's a rule but what's
really funny mister
speaker
is if i have a valid
new hampshire concealed carry license
i
can carry
a gun on a snowmobile or atv
but if i don't
i can't
that is pretty silly so that is what
this bill does it just repeals that
section
so we need to repeal it and get rid of
it so lastly mr speaker
house bill 334 is a housekeeping bill to
make constitutional carry
in line with all vehicles
i asked my friends on both sides of the
aisle to send that person that vetoed
this bill
a clear message that new hampshire wants
a accurate
constitutional carry
so mr speaker i am sure you will join me
and please press that beautiful bright
green button and i want to thank you mr
speaker
the chair recognizes representative
abramson can speak for the override
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker i uh stand in favor of uh
pressing the green button and uh passing
this bill in spite of the governor's
veto
and the reason is and what i tried to
bring up in the first time this bill
came through a debate is what happens if
somebody's out on a trail head or
somebody's out
out in the forest or out in the field
somewhere they have their uh they have
their ohrv and they also have their
firearm
the current uh
fish and game rule
tells many people that they literally
have to abandon their firearm on the
trail
and i felt that that was a dangerous
situation and that that isn't something
when i used to teach firearm safety i
would never have suggested anything as
absurd as that and yet that's
essentially what fish and game the fish
and game role does under those
admittedly rare circumstances the state
should never
under any circumstances tell people to
do that they have to do the unsafe thing
that if somebody does have a firearm or
if someone in their party has a firearm
they should never have to abandon their
firearm you should be allowed to take
your firearm with you back to your truck
or back to your your home and uh and
transport it i think that that's just a
matter of principle now there is an rsa
627 section 3 the competing harms
defense if you were ever charged you
could theoretically take this to court
and say that you're trying to prevent a
greater competing harm
but nobody should ever be
fined and have to
have to take that issue up i i think
that the
the state should never have a rule ever
that tells people that they have to do
something that's unsafe
remember yield to a question
yes i will remember yields thank you mr
speaker thank you for taking my question
i'm not a hunter i'm not a snowmobiler
or any of that stuff there but i do see
stories of bear
wolves coyote throughout new hampshire
when you're on our trails
and you can't have a loaded gun
how do you handle that if you come
across one of them black bears or
coyote or anything
without a around in your weapon i mean
how do you do that
well if you're on a trail and you're
attacked by a bear you better hope that
you're an army guy
uh because uh if you're unarmed uh you
better be a lot tougher than the average
average uh bear
uh but yeah you're right
you've got to have a firearm to defend
yourself i'll tell you that even though
seabrook is actually strangely
considered part of a you know urban
compact it's considered an urban zone by
the u.s census
we have wild animals going through my
backyard all the time literally all the
time we've had everything from fisher
cats to cougars and other other types of
animals coming through seabrook or
mountain lions i should say
this member yield to another question
uh it's getting awful loud in here awful
lot of chatter we can hear up here
members have a right to be heard
yes he is going to yield thank you he's
going to yield to another question
remember may inquire
um thank you mr speaker
not you not your representative
wait a minute
sorry betty it's back here all the way
behind you
thank you mr speaker thank you member
for asking the question it would
surprise you to know that i spoke to
fish and game about this bill and the
executive director they have not
enforced this law since we passed
constitutional carry for that same exact
reason and that they would support a
clean bill
in a future date
does the member yield to a further
question
um i would say i would say that the bill
is a clean bill i don't i i do not
understand what the objection is with
the language
associated with it from the governor's
veto message
uh yes i will take another question
representative you may inquire thank you
mr speaker my concern is not the intent
of the bill
all of it sounds good to me i support
the right to bear arms
my concern is that this seeds some
authority from new hampshire officials
to grant
permission to purchase a gun
the last several years have shown us
that representative you were
you were
asking a question
yes how does uh how does this bill
protect us
if we leave it as intact all the all the
sections of it how does this bill
protect us from capricious response by
the fbi
in another state very difficult to reach
how does it protect us
by removing the new hampshire
arm of the processors of purchasing a
gun the gun line how does this protect
us
from
i i i deny by denying our our access to
the gun line
all right so i i think i understand the
question i i believe that this uh issue
was discussed when the bill went through
committee the first time and i i didn't
hear anyone
raise that objection from the actual
language of the bill so i don't agree
with what the question is implying
okay
yeah just uh just a gentle reminder that
uh you should refer to a fellow
representative as representative not
their first name thank you
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of the member is
president oh i'm sorry
chair recognizes representative muse
from uh to uh speak to sustain the
governor's veto
thank you mr speaker
colleagues today i rise to urge you to
vote no to sustain the veto of hb 334
as originally passed by the house hb 334
would have allowed operators in the past
and passengers on ohrvs and snowmobiles
to carry loaded pistols or revolvers
but when the bill came back to us from
the other body it was amended to include
much of the language of another bill a
controversial bill that would eliminate
the role of the state police gun line
and handgun background checks
as was stated in the veto message
changes to the background check process
are no longer needed
the pandemic may still be with us but
the staffing issues the technology
issues and the process issues that led
to frustrating delays for would-be
handgun buyers during the first months
of cobit have been fixed
domestic violence advocates have also
warned us that eliminating the state
police role in handgun background checks
would open up dangerous holes in the
system that would leave more victims
vulnerable to domestic violence homicide
hb 30 hb 334 would also shift
responsibility for conducting background
checks prior to the return of firearms
to people subject to protective orders
from the state police to county sheriffs
while the bill appropriates ten thousand
dollars for each county sheriff to pay
for training in computer systems
this amounts to only a small fraction of
what larger counties will need
colleagues
this bill is not only unnecessary and
potentially dangerous it's also an
unfunded mandate for new hampshire
counties that endangers members of the
public who deserve our protection
please join me in voting no to sustain
this veto
thank you
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of remembrance
president voting is required to override
a veto if you're in favor of having the
bill become law you will press the green
button if you are opposed and wish to
stay in the governor's veto you will
press the red button
loading stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative alexander
representative stephen boyd
representative bunker
representative cannon representative
kaplan representative cleaver
representative clutier representative
connors
representative cross
representative goalie
representative petrigno
representative osborne osborne's not
here
representative janice schmidt
representative tausch thank you
representative welkowitz thank you
that should be it
representative clutter we have you
you're good thank you
i think we're all so
nope
if all members voted that were present
the house will sustain the
vote
138 voting yay 212 voting nay
the governor's veto is sustained
mr speaker point of order
at a1
hi mr speaker i just want to point out
that roll call is being announced by
the sergeant-at-arms while the 30-second
window is enacted
that is not usually enough time to make
it from the restroom to come vote
and just wanted to point that out so we
can have
time for people to make it back for the
vote
thank you
pointing the water well taken we'll make
sure we do better
so without objection we're going to take
up those two amendments
okay can i have everyone's attention
please
we're waiting for
senate bill 38 to come over from the
senate
it seems that they're going to override
the governor's veto on that bill
the senate hasn't started yet because it
seems that a number of their members are
caught in traffic trying to get to
the state house
so
and we can't adjourn from 2021 until we
take up that particular veto
without objection we can take up the
amendments to rules
okay
representative osborne and shirtless
move
the the proposed amendment to house
rules
printed in calendar
house rule 66.
are you ready for the question
[Music]
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it by the two thirds
uh the chair now recognizes
representative weber for
a motion
to an amendment for house rules
house rule 67
thank you mr speaker i move an amendment
that has been handed out to rule 67 and
i asked to speak to my motion
you may you're recognized to speak thank
you
uh the amendment is drawn is a very
simple amendment which permits but does
not require
remote access
for the house its committees and
subcommittees
so
if we need to
use remote access
we do not have a rule have have a rules
change in order to do it
i know that people have raised the issue
of rsa 91a which requires the presence
of a quorum that has been resolved by
the supreme court
it's ruled that a presence of a quorum
may be determined electronically
i also note that our rules are of higher
priority than state statute
and the courts have affirmed the ability
of the house to set its own rules
most importantly
this provision
if passed and implemented
would not only provide for safe access
both for members
and for the public
but
it is a provision that increases public
participation
public observation
and public comment rather than
decreasing it so i would ask you to join
me in pushing the green button thank you
mr speaker
the chair recognizes the member from
charlestown representative smith
thank you mr speaker
so my first objection to this proposed
rules amendment is that it's a concept
and not a plan
we've had multiple talks about how you
would actually implement something like
this and so far i haven't seen anything
realistic that would work
this is at best premature
second
my experience over the past well what
now two years of us meeting virtually is
that the house members have come to
regard each other as talking heads on a
screen
because of that i believe our processes
are broken down there's more animosity
less collegiality and it's really
important that we get back to that
something like this should not be done
lightly a complete well thought out plan
should be presented and just as an idea
i cannot support this
has requested a roll call members will
take their seats
is that i'm sorry i'll get there it's
been six months is that officially
seconded
it is sufficiently second this will be a
roll call vote
[Music]
so
mr speaker at d1
i have a an actual parliamentary inquiry
and that is um
at this point to pass a rule change is
it a majority or two-thirds two-thirds
thank you
okay no it's
members will take their seats this is
going to be a roll call vote members
need to be in their seats
the chair recognizes representative
spedia for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
friends if i believe that safe
participation should be available to
members and the public
and if i believe that we are still
navigating this pandemic where things
continue to be shifting
and if i believe that we successfully
navigated the remote accessing committee
last year
then would i now vote green to amend
house rule 67 thank you
the chair recognizes the representative
stephen smith for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker if in addition to
the concerns i cited earlier i also
believe that there can be constitutional
issues with allowing the house to meet
completely virtually
then would i press the red button
the question is on the amendment to
house rule 67
this is a roll call vote
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are
question for polled speaker
i've already put the question we're in
the voting mode right now
inquiry of the speaker
we're in the voting mode
representative
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative shapiro
representative welkowitz
representative simon
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
169 voting yay 186 voting may
the amendment fails question for the
speaker
make your inquiry
thank you mr speaker
you've gone on record a couple of times
in the public eye
saying that the reason that we cannot
have remote participation is because we
do not have a rule and when given the
opportunity just now your party voted
down that rule what will your excuse be
now
that
representative that question's out of
line right now
okay this is
this is the uh
predicament we're in right now
the house is going to have to be in
recess until we get
senate bill 38 from the senate
i i can't tell you if that's going to be
five minutes 10 minutes or a half an
hour but as soon as we get it
we asked everybody to return to your
seats as soon as possible
we're in recess
members take your seats
we have senate bill 38
once we get through that we have to take
another break
members take your seats please
the chair recognizes the clerk for a
message
thank you mr speaker mr speaker the
senate has voted to override the
governor's veto on the following bill
senate bill 38 relative to the
organization of alternative treatment
centers
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on senate bill 38
relative to organization of alternative
treatment centers
the question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's veto so
senate bill 38 become law
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of members
president voting is required to override
a veto
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
the chair recognizes
this will be a roll call vote
[Music]
i'm married
members take your seats please
the sooner you take your seats the
sooner we can move on
we need to
maintain
silence while we're
working on bills so everyone can hear
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds vote of the members
president voting is required to override
a veto
the chair recognizes
representative hunt for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker since i have voted against
this bill multiple times
and i voted against it because it was in
the deal that was made that these were
going to be non-profit
so that marijuana
was not sold in a way that would be a
profit making business
if mr speaker if i truly believe
that there is no need to pass this
legislation that these marijuana medic
centers are already well financed by the
owners
of marijuana
facilities
across the country
would i now
vote to sustain the governor's veto
this will be a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative bartlett for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the
alternative treatment centers are very
important to many new hampshire folks
and if i know that financing these
centers is particularly difficult
as non-profits which they are now
restricted to be
and if i know that allowing them to be
organized as a for-profit company just
as any other business can be
would i now press the green button to
override the governor's veto thank you
this will be a roll call vote if you're
in favor of the bill becoming law you
will press the green button
if you are opposed and wish to sustain
the governor's veto you will plus you
will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative allegro representative
avaloni representative bean
representative bullier representative
belanger
representative binford representative
cannon representative cleaver
representative deshay
representative dodge
representative fellowes
representative edgar
representative harley
we have you representative bullier
we've got it
representative
van you're all set
hold on
representative cannon you're all set
hayward
you're good
just
representative
avalani just
it's not registering can you come closer
please
crazy
i don't think
oh
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attain to the state of
the vote
228 voting 115 voting nay
it fails lacking the necessary two
thirds
we're going to be in recess
representative osborne moves at the
house adjourned from the 2021 session
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the first
year session of the 167th general court
of new hampshire house of
representatives stan's adjourned
the house is in recess for approximately
30 minutes while staff prepares us for
next year 2022
so
more donuts
members please take your seats we are a
minute and a half away
i'm sure everybody
however
okay
members take your seats we're ready to
go
members take your seats
before we get going
i would just like to
remind everybody that unfortunately the
acoustics in this building aren't the
greatest
so if we have a lot of chatter members
are having a tough time hearing
so i'm asking that you all take into
consideration
all of your colleagues in this room
and keep you try and keep your chatter
down to
absolutely nil if you have to have a
conversation maybe just shoot out into
the hallway
so all the members can hear
this day january 5th 2022 first
wednesday following the first tuesday in
january being the day designated by the
constitution part two article three
for assembling of the second year
session of the 167th general court of
the state of new hampshire the expo
center and doubletree by hilton in the
city of manchester
the 2022 house of representatives is now
convened
the house will be attentive while we
call the role of the house using the
roll call system
please press your green button
one second
two seconds
three seconds and we're good
uh
okay the house will be attended to roll
call using the roll call system please
press your green button for attendance
so
members to be clear this is the call of
the role to establish a quorum to begin
the new session
please make sure you are pressing your
buttons
oh
have all members present voted press
your green button
representative binford come on down
please
representative leon please do not hit
the voting device
sorry
so
representatives
as everybody
voted
press their green button okay
with 300
with 351
members having answered the call
the chair declares a quorum present
the house will attend to a memorial
resolution
house resolution number 19
memorializing state representative
barbara shaw of manchester
whereas we have learned with profound
sorrow of the death of our friend and
colleague barbara e shaw
who was serving her 11th term as a state
representative representing the citizens
of manchester's ward 9.
and whereas a dedicated advocate of
education
barbara shaw spent her life as an
educator and administrator
and once becoming a member of the house
served eight of her 11 terms on the
education committee
serving as clerk of that committee a
remarkable five times
and whereas a committed public servant
at every level of life
barbara shaw was concurrently serving as
alderman in manchester's ward 9 and was
the longest serving female alderman in
the city's history
and whereas barbara shaw cared about
people and would often show up to assist
a constituent in moving
assist the homeless with errands and
support
hear every side of an issue from every
concerned citizen and was admired for
her sincerity and honesty
and whereas barbara shaw was a devoted
wife
mother and grandmother who took a
measurable pride in her family
and will be forever known as a staple in
manchester's lower
now therefore be it resolved by the
house of representatives in regular
session convened barbara eashaw be
granted the highest praise and accolades
and our profound thanks for her service
to the state and the city she called
home
and be it further resolved that
expressions of our most heartfelt
sympathy be extended to our family that
a suitable copy of this resolution be
prepared for presentation to them
offered by the house of representatives
everybody please rise and join me in a
moment of silence and honor the memory
of honorable barbara shaw of manchester
okay before we get into the next order
of business uh just for
your knowledge
uh they're going to start distributing
the meals around
quarter of
and once all the meals are distributed
uh we will take a half hour to 45 minute
break
but their meals will be distributed for
us we'll probably be around 12 30.
the house will attend to a motion to
suspend house rules
mr speaker representatives stephen smith
and shirtless move that all necessary
house rules be so far suspended so as to
allow introduction and consideration at
the present time of house bill 1650
relative to mileage for members of the
legislature without the required
referral to committee public hearing and
report from committee and if passed
allow for immediate third reading
i
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested all
members take your seats
division
so
okay
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
stephen smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the rules committee
approved this
in the unanimous bipartisan vote and
that as long as we allow suspension of
the rules we'll get to talk about the
substance of the bill
would i press the green button
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent bully are you all set
representative ammon
representative burudi
represent bergeron
representative freitas
representative harley representative
johnson
representative levitt
representative john mcdonald
representative lachmann
representative rudy you're all set now
thank you
representative johnson you're all set
representative nunes
representative mcbride
hold on just a minute
i'll start representing this
it's good
representative friedas you're all set
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
i also attend to the state of the vote
317 voting yay
40 voting nay
suspension of the rules passes
uh
clerk
house will attend to a resolution mr
speaker representative osborne offers
the following resolved in accordance
with the list in the possession of the
clerk house bill number 1650 shall be by
this resolution read a first and second
time
are you ready for the question
for what reason does the member rise
i call for a division vote and i'd like
to do a pi
the division has been requested all
members will take their seats
division
speakers
representative stephen pearson
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative silvia
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
that this bill has not had a public
hearing
and
if i know
that this bill
will assure that our house chamber
becomes
a museum
and furthermore if i know that this
bill
further perpetuates
of a pandemic that has come to an end
would i then press the red button
house will come to water
the chair recognizes representative
stephen smith for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the proper way to do this
and debate the substance of the bill is
to introduce it then would i press the
green button
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative phildolfi
representative harley
representative mcguire
vol members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
326 voting yay 34 vote in may
the resolution is adopted
representative
representative stephen smith moves that
house bill 1650
ought to pass
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
the eyes have it
recognize the clerk for a third reading
motion
mr speaker representative osborne moves
that house bill 1650 relative to mileage
for members of the legislature be by be
read by title only and that it be read a
third time by this resolution and that
its title be the same as adopted and
that it be passed at the present time
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
where are we
okay
that
house will attend to a resolution
mr speaker representative osborne offers
the following resolved in accordance
with the list in the possession of the
clerk house bills numbered 1000 through
1076 through 1208
1210 through 1224 126 to 1300 1302
through 1470
1472 through 1478 1480 through 1609 1611
through 1649 1651 through 1685
and 2022 house concurrent resolutions
numbered six through nine house
resolutions numbered fifteen through
eighteen and constitutional amendment
concurrent resolutions numbered thirteen
through fifteen and seventeen through
thirty five shall be by this resolution
read a first and second time by their
enlisted titles and referred to the
there and designated committees
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the resolution is
adopted
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
mr speaker from the committee on
criminal justice and public safety house
bill 408 removed by representative lynn
from the committee on criminal justice
and public safety house bill 526 removed
by representative abramson
from the committee on election law house
bill 362 removed by representative
silber
from the committee on transportation
house bill 116 removed by representative
guthrie
are there any other bills to be removed
from the consent calendar
representative osborne moves at the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments that's printed in the
day's house record be adopted are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the consent
calendar is adopted
under rules of the house from the
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs house bill 314 is
referred to the committee on executive
departments and administration
representative scitec declared a
conflict of interest on house bill 498
do not participate in the vote on the
consent calendar
the house will now attend to bills on
the regular calendar
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred house bill 60
an act raising the minimum age of
marriage having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution that it is inexpedient to
legislate so joshua keller for the
committee
the chair recognizes
representative
levesque
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i have presented to the committee with
research from numerous child advocacy
groups such as
unicef unchained at last tahari justice
center and the new hampshire chapter of
the national society of social workers
that shows the effects of child marriage
has on young girls
the committee heard testimony from
multiple survivors of child marriage and
how it has horrifically affected their
lives
this information has been presented to
the committee numerous times not once
has anyone or any organization
presented data to support that opinion
that child marriage has any benefits to
children
in the committee it was brought up that
new hampshire needs to have child
marriage in case of teen pregnancy
it is a fact that new hampshire rates 51
out of 52 states for the lowest teen
pregnancy
rates in the u.s
we have combated teen pregnancy and we
are winning that battle
also it has been argued that we need to
allow child marriage
to allow their soldiers sweetheart
because they could be shipped off to war
i asked what war the u.s is not at war
child marriage directly impacts girls
education
health psychological well-being and the
health of their offspring
it increases the risk of depression
anxiety and bipolar disorders
sexually transmitted infections
cervical cancer obstructive fistulas and
maternal mortality
their offspring are an increased risk
for premature birth
and subsequently neonatal or infant
death
young girls in child marriages are
denied an appropriate childhood and
adolescence and are subject to increased
incidence of psychological abuse as well
as domestic violence
a curving of personal liberty and
incomplete education and a lack of
employment and career prospects
we have seen parents bring their
children across borders to have them
married before and hampshire stand on
the cusp of becoming child marriage
wedding destination
i am sure that's something we do not
want for new hampshire
new hampshire is a choice and we can
continue to be part of the global
child forced marriage human trafficking
problem where we can stay
stand against this
six states have seen the harm that child
marriage does
it made the decision to end child
marriage so i ask you why can't we thank
you
mr speaker
the house will be in order
question for what members of member rise
will the member yield to a question
does the member yield to a question
uh looks like no thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes the member from hudson
representative rice to speak for the
committee report
good morning thank you mr speaker i rise
in support of the majority majority
committee recommendation of itl on hb60
a few years ago the age of marriage was
raised to 16.
currently parental and judicial consent
is needed and clear and convincing
evidence that the marriage is in the
best interest of the persons below the
age of consent must be presented
in 2019 there were zero underage
marriages and in 2020 there were five
all of whom were 17 years old
these were informed decisions made
between parents the judiciary and the
persons under the age of consent
after seeing these numbers the majority
of the committee felt that this was
trying to fix a problem that doesn't
exist in new hampshire
please support the majority
recommendation of itl and press the
green button thank you
mr speaker question
does the member yield to a question
the member yields thank you thank you mr
speaker mr speaker uh matt thank you for
taking my question
as a chairman of veterans affairs and
somebody that served 22 years on active
duty
many military people show up 17 18 year
olds with brides that are 16 17 18 years
many of them are pregnant i are you
aware this was this brought up and i
thank you for what you did in your
committee yes i'm aware thank you thank
you
the question is on
house bill 60
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate
are you ready for the question
we had to wait for the division before
we called for the parliamentary
inquiries so our division has been
called for so members take your seats
this will be a division vote
[Music]
so
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
altruller for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that choosing a
partner is a major decision
one that should be made freely and
without fear or coercion
in new hampshire marriage is a contract
that everyone should be able to enter
into and exit out of without an aged
based penalty and if i know that 83
percent of children in forced marriages
are girls and that the u.s state
department calls marriage before the age
of 18 a human rights abuse that produces
devastating repercussions for a girl's
life effectively ending her childhood
and finally if i know that children in
the new here in new hampshire who must
seek parental and judicial approval to
enter into a contract
which they then may not exit
until they actually reach the age of
majority is a travesty we cannot keep
turning away from
then will i now take action to end child
marriage in new hampshire by pressing
the red button to vote no so that
another motion can be made
the chair recognizes representative
nelson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that currently judicial and
parental consent is required for any
person under the age of consent to marry
if i also know that clear and convincing
evidence that the marriage is in the
best interest
of both persons below the age of consent
must be present to a judge
and if i also know that this bill is
trying to correct an issue that does not
exist in new hampshire
would i now press the green button and
uphold the majority committee
recommendation of itl
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative baruti representative
bullier representative cannon
representative deshase
representative harley
representative
huff it is
right
representative leon just come a little
closer and try again
got it
represent van houten
she's
you try again
try again
got it
thank you
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
192 voting
voting nay
committee report is adopted
mr speaker
um
i asked that uh the remarks of the
previous debate be placed in the
permanent journal
the just what we just had
okay
without objection
the committee on children and family law
which was referred house bill 228
act relative to the calculation of child
support in cases with equal or
approximately equal parenting time and
we considered the same report the same
with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator joshua
keller for the committee
the amendment is 2116
h printed in house record 48 page
87. are you ready for the question
on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes represent
the question is now on the emotion of
ought to pass as amended
the chair recognizes representative long
from manchester to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in opposition to the
art of pass as amended recommendation to
house bill 228
i do believe that this issue must be
addressed however i also agree that in
an effort in reducing conflict between
parents and divorce courts that the
details of addressing this should be
reviewed in detail assuring that
reduction in conflict is attained
one concern are the cases with domestic
violence what additional burden could
this bill deliver for a parent's secret
financial relief with little or no
thought of the best interest of the
child or children solely thinking that
the more time spent with my child the
greater potential with reducing my
support payments
i ask this house to vote no on the ought
to pass as a mended recommendation thank
you mr speaker
the chair recognizes rep the member from
fremont representative o'calla to speak
in favor of the committee report
thank you mr speaker i'm at d2
i rise in support of hb
228.
the supreme court has interpreted the
current language
in statute to say that adjustments
cannot be made because of parenting time
which effectively turns child support
into alimony and the calculation is
entirely based on money and not based on
who is actually parenting
this amendment and this bill now
seeks to remedy the confusion the
current language has caused in the
supreme court
so i
advocate for you to
vote green thank you very
much representative long has requested a
division vote members take your seats
division
the house will come to order the chair
recognizes representative long for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i believe that is my
responsibility to reduce conflict and
divorce courts
then would i
then would i press the red button and
defeat this ought to pass motion thank
you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative
ocala for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i believe that
child support should be based on who
supports the child
and if i believe that addressing the
hardship this confusion has caused
is of the highest priority would i now
vote in favor of this motion by pressing
the green button thank you
the question is on house bill 228 ought
to pass as amended this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
speaking of
um i'm going to ask members that have
had some problems with their clickers
connecting from a distance to just move
a little bit closer where it did take
before so that it does
correct
representative bordenay
representative dolan representative
eaton
representative frost
representative huff
representative
leon is right there
representative mann
right here
representative renzullo
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
189 voting yay 163
voting nay the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
commerce and consumer affairs to which
was referred house bill 65 an act
requiring food service establishments to
establish food allergy awareness
procedures
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill re be referred for interim study
jeffrey greeson for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative joyce weston from
the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative the
member from plymouth representative
weston to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
rachel hunger for whom this bill is
named
was 21 years old in a molecular
genetics student at unh
she was out with friends for dinner one
evening and when she ordered an egg roll
she was unaware that it contained peanut
paste
rachel had a peanut allergy she died
that night
h.b 65 called rachel's law
is a long overdue consumer protection
bill
which arose from that tragedy
it's been studied long enough
the proposed interim study
will delay the process only further
opening up
the possibility of another mistake like
the one that took rachel's life
the majority in commerce claims that
this issue
should be handled handled by dhhs rules
process
but if that's a workable solution why
are we still waiting for change years
later
we need food allergy awareness now
we need training of restaurant employees
now
responsibility needs to be taken by both
sides
the restaurant and the customer now
this bill would benefit both the
restaurant owner and the consumer as a
matter of fact its language came from a
collaboration
of the new hampshire lodging and
restaurant association and the prime
sponsor
together they determined that
restaurants should place a simple notice
on menus
stating that it's the obligation of the
customer to inform the server about
their food allergy
we already have a similar note
on menus about the dangers of eating raw
food
so it's very easy for us to do it for
food allergies
thank you
chair recognizes the member from ridge
representative hunt
to speak for the committee report
uh mr speaker at uh d2s representative
greeson uh in for uh speaking for
representative hunt
okay
representative greeson thank you sir mr
speaker and fellow representatives the
majority of the members of the commerce
committee recommend that house bill 65
be referred for interim study in order
to allow the department of health and
human services to enact an appropriate
rule governing food handling safety such
as it pertains to allergens referring to
house bill 65
for interim study in no means kills this
bill or avoids taking any action rather
this is precisely the same means
used for getting warning statements
about consuming raw or undercooked
foods added to the bottom of menus and
it is precisely the same means used
regarding water quality levels in
bottled water the difference between
house bill 65 and those other bills is
house bill 65 comes with a tragic death
that can be exploited when presented
with an opportunity to actually
accomplish the objective in a manner
that was agreeable under less emotional
circumstances the minority chose to play
on emotions claiming that if it would
save even one life it would be worth
doing but then they promptly rejected
the opportunity to actually do something
in a more effective and efficient manner
in fact using rules vice legislation is
the better means of accomplishing this
objective it is more efficient and more
effective and it ensures legislative
oversight in short it works very well so
please vote with the committee
recommendation to refer house bill 65
for interim study thank you
for what reason remember rising
pardon
state your point of order
mr speaker recently
a number of us participated in a
workshop to return civility
to politics in this house
one of our long-standing rules is that
we don't assign
thoughts
to the opposition
i believe that i was offended by what
was just said about the minorities
intentions
in that
speech that was just given and i i would
like to bring it to folks attention that
there's no reason
to charge people
with negative
intent thank you
i would like to remind everybody
of one of our
pretty much
unwritten rules i guess you would call
it that we do not refer to
another member
or the minority or the majority
in any kind of a derogatory way so i
would ask that all members
please be careful when you
are
delivering a speech
the question before us is on house bill
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
division
okay
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes
representative abel for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that rachel's law is a long
overdue
life-saving bill
with overwhelming support from the
public
and from the restaurant association of
new hampshire
which helped draft the bill
and i know the bill has already been
thoroughly studied
an interim study will only delay its
implementation
then
when i push
the red button to defeat this motion so
another motion may be made thank you
the chair recognizes representative
ammon for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker i'm over at d1
mr speaker if i know that
our restaurants in the state are already
struggling because of the pandemic and
that we want to be very careful to add
additional burdens
on them
and mr speaker if i know the interim
study doesn't kill the bill but it
leaves the bill in the commerce
committee
and mr speaker if i know that the proper
way to implement this is through rules
and that those rules are being worked on
right now would i then press the green
button
the question before us is on house bill
65 the majority report of interim study
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
we're good
representative hatch
representative sue newman
representative diane kelly
represent man
representative oxenam
representative sue newman
i got you representative newman thank
you
represent van
represent man if you could come down
representative
van as well
represent van i got you
representative man can you try from
there
okay
it came through
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
under a 94 voting a 164 voting nay
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 92
enact establishing at a committee to
study
the best practices for companion animal
groomers
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
senator john hunt for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative nito
burroughs for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
pearl's
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise today in support of hp
92 which establishes a committee to
study the best practices for companion
animal groomers
a company to study animal grooming
regulation can protect the public and
lower the cost of doing business
safety issues pursuant to animal
grooming include waste and chemical
disposal
safety and facility standards that
protect both the animals and groomers
and the risk of personal injury
dogs do die in grooming facilities and
most of these deaths are preventable
dogs are not the only ones at risk
workers have been bitten by dogs that
can weigh up to 250 pounds
people are also susceptible to zoonic
diseases which can spread between
animals and people these can be viral
bacterial or fungal
animal grooming facilities must meet
osha standards for health safety
equipment sterility and potential
injuries what is the purpose of a
committee to look at this issue it is to
ensure that these facilities protect the
public and companion animals from
potential armed and to avoid unnecessary
liability costs in less ensure and thus
ensure that costs to the public remain
low
the most important reason to pass this
legislation is to protect these small
businesses from the cost of a lengthy
and costly legal proceeding
relating to the death or injury
of a companion animal or employee
a committee would explore options to
minimize the expense and hardship to pet
grooming businesses by virtue of
preventable deaths and injury to both
animals and human
i ask you to please vote against the
committee recommendation of itl by
pushing the red button thank you mr
speaker
the chair recognizes representative
patuck to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
thank you colleagues
i'll keep this short and sweet
mr speaker i know that this bill was
well intended and it is meant to guide
dog groomers so that they can do their
jobs professionally and with best
practices
unfortunately i also know that this
would create yet another
commission to study something
and i also know that there are no
national regulating bodies setting
standards for this commission to
investigate
so
this commission will basically be
wasting its time by trying to get the
government involved trying to regulate
something
with nothing
thank you mr speaker
division has been requested members will
take their seats
division
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
bartlett for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that there are no common and
uniform standards for pet grooming
and if i know many groomers would like
to study this issue
if i know this is only a study committee
not a commission
and no mandate nor licensing are
involved
and if i know many of us care deeply
about our pets and how they're handled
what i vote no so another motion can be
brought forward thank you
the chair recognizes representative hunt
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know
that there are no national standards
there's no regulations to ensure that
there's safe
practices so mr speaker if i know
there's no need
to have a study committee if you're not
seeking licensure or regulation
that i now vote with the committee and
kill house bill 92 by pressing the green
button
the question is on house bill 92 the
majority report have been expedient to
legislate
this is a division vote
if you're on favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
okay representative testerman
representative tausch
representative woods
representative petry
representative page
representative osborne
representative melvin
representative clee representative gay
representative
kelly
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
197 voting yay 159 voting may the
committee report is
adopted are we all done
everybody's got it
has everybody received their lunch
orders
so
it seems like i think everybody that
ordered a lunch has a lunch
so what we're going to do now is take a
break
it's about quarter past 12
we will reconvene exactly at one o'clock
also be in recess
members take your seats
the house will come to order
the clerk has a couple of announcements
before we get going again
thank you mr speaker a couple of quick
things
if you are parked on the fourth floor
outside in the garage here
uh obviously you all know about the icy
situation going on right now
if you need to leave early before the
thought comes this afternoon
be very careful it is very icy and we
need to make sure you're healthy and
happy
secondly
members of the house and legislative
staff are only allowed in this room at
any given time no
outside folks lobbyists etc are allowed
on the floor thank you mr speaker
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 166
enact relative to safety requirements
for pools on foreclosed residential
property having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate presented keith airman from
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered this the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass
senator richard abel for the minority of
the committee
the chair recognizes
the member from seabrook representative
abramson to speak for the committee
report
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in favor of
the
inexpedient to legislate motion on house
bill 166 and i want to thank members of
the minority for bringing this issue to
our attention
it is a life and death issue but we went
through
as a committee into the details of the
details
and what we found was that statistically
deaths in pools on foreclosed properties
are very rare nationwide
and statistically at best i think i uh
we estimated that at best you could save
one life every 90 80 to 90 years
however because
some of the pool cover designs could
potentially also lead to drownings that
it probably even though it's also a
statistically small number it might be a
safety rule that could potentially
cause more
deaths than it prevents or cause more
drownings than it prevents so for that
reason we decided
that we couldn't fix the bill as it was
and we made the motion to itl
please press the green button
the chair recognizes the member from
west lebanon representative pabl to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
this bill is about two things
protecting new hampshire children from
accidental injury
or death by drowning
in pools on
unoccupied foreclosed property
it's also
about helping reduce the liability of
lenders
who now own
such occupied
unoccupied foreclosed property
by encouraging protective coverings for
pools on their foreclosed property
i've been asked how common a threat is
drowning
we have all
we have all long known about the danger
of attractive nuisances
such as open pools and how they affect
how they attract and affect children
what many of us may not know
is that drowning is among the top five
causes of death
for children
i've also been asked who would be
affected by the passage of this bill
this bill only applies
to foreclosed property
property
which
in which the ownership has been returned
to the lender through the foreclosure
procedures
it does not affect individuals who live
on the premises
those still facing foreclosure
nor does it affect
those who whose property was foreclosed
let me just
repeat this the requirement to secure a
pool
on on occupied foreclosed property
only applies to the lender
not to the borrower
this bill promotes realistic safety
precautions
and sensibly reduces the lender's risk
of potential liability that could occur
on the premises i ask you to think
carefully about the excellent reasons
for supporting hp
and vote down the very close 10 to 9
recommendation
so that and an
alternative motion may be brought
forward thank you very much
chair i recognize the member from new
boston representative airman to speak
for the community report
representative is waving off
a division has been called members will
take their seats
[Music]
roll call has been
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
for what reason remember rise
if i could do a pi mr speaker we already
have one thank you
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
weston for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that pooled deaths are among
the top five causes of children's deaths
and if i know that this bill will
protect the banks handling the
foreclosure as well as curious
neighborhood kids
and if i also know that the lender would
shoulder the expense of the pool cover
not the foreclosed property owner when i
not push the red button to defeat this
motion so another motion can be made
the chair recognizes representative hunt
for parliamentary recording thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker if i know that when the
commerce committee heard this bill
we learned that this is actually fannie
mae
so anybody who has a fannie mae loan
which is about 60 percent of loans
already have this statute and if the
commerce committee was very concerned
when they heard testimony from code
enforcers and saying how are they
possibly going to enforce this let alone
the landlord or the owner of the
property doesn't exist anymore because
it's foreclosed property
so
would i now support the commerce
committee's decision to make this bill
in expedience to legislate
the question is on house bill 166 the
majority report been expedient to
legislate it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative ammon
representative avalon you're all set
represent ammon it's not working
it's good now thank you
represent paige
you're all set representative leon thank
you
representative infantine you're fine
representative
mcdonald you're fine
representative de shays you're fine
represent brombo you're all set
yep
all right
can't leave
so
represent roy
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
oh
the house will tend to the state of the
vote
186 gays 160 nays committee report is
adopted
oh i'm sorry
senator baxter has declared a conflict
of interest and did not participate in
the vote
mr speaker
e1
yes
point of order
are hats allowed on the in the house
while we're
in session
the the gentlemen are not supposed to be
wearing hats thank you
majority of committee on commerce and
consumer affairs was referred house bill
an act relative to prior authorizations
and patient transfers under managed care
group health insurance policies having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate president of
john hunt for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
been considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass
senate joyce western from the minority
of the committee
the chair recognizes the member from
plymouth representative weston to speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
we've recently seen a significant
increase in the use of prior
authorizations by group healthcare
providers
this increase has resulted in long
delays in patient care while the
insurance care
carriers decide about the authorization
this bill does not ban or impede prior
authorizations
it simply extends the period that they
remain valid
from a mere three months to six months
it was brought forward at the request of
the new hampshire association
excuse me the new hampshire hospital
association
to address the problems of delays in
care
administrative complexities
and outright denials of payments to
providers
the medical community wants this change
because it will make patient care better
reduce the level of frustration
reduce the amount of wasted time and
money from the medical staff
this change is supported by the new
hampshire medical society
and five physician specialty
organizations
the bill also erases administrative
burdens on hospital staff
by facilitating the transfer
of a patient to a more appropriate level
of care
in a timely manner one business day
it's a simple
but cost effective change
particularly in this time of extreme
medical burden due to the pandemic
this bill would both improve care and
save money
we hope that you'll vote against the itl
chair recognizes the member from rindge
representative hunt to speak for the
committee report
thank you very much mr speaker
uh mr speaker this uh this bill has uh
two mandates in one
uh both are uh was driven by the
hospital association and basically they
want to make their lives a little bit
easier so that they don't have to make
phone calls to the insurance companies
to make sure that the patient actually
has insurance or has the coverage that
they're asking for prior approval on
the three-month standard is true for all
the states around us so there's nothing
new there there's nothing special no
reason to change it and in terms of the
transfer no that's just going to cost
more money for the insurance so the
commerce committee was not about to pass
a new mandate that was just going to
cost more premium so please support the
committee
question before the
question before the house
is the
inexpedient to legislative motion on
house bill 191
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
division
[Music]
so
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
bartlett for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that prior
authorizations are usually effective for
only three months
if i further know it may take longer
than three months for appointments with
certain specialties to even be scheduled
and if i know that
this would ease the administrative
burdens and thus save some health care
dollars
if i further know the new hampshire
hospital association requested the small
change to six months
no change in coverage
would i press the no button so another
motion can be brought forward thank you
chair recognizes representative hunt for
a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that no mandate
comes without a cost will i now vote yes
on the unexpedient legislature
the question is on house bill 191 the
majority report have been expedient to
legislate
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
representative growing
representative gottling
representative eamon kelly
represent murder
representative sweeney
representative tolle
representative true
representative tucker
all members president had the
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
190 voting a 162 voting made committee
reports adopted
the clerk has a report to read
mr speaker the committee on enrolled
bills has examined and found correctly
enrolled the following titled house bill
house bill 1650 relative to mileage for
members of the legislature
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 245 act relative to
the definition of grocery or convenience
store having considered the same report
the same the recommendation that the
bill referred for interim study driven
to john hunt for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same may be
unable to agree with the majority report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass incentive max abramson
from the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
abramson to speak against the committee
report
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the majority report to
refer for interim study
for one simple reason that this
republican platform bill is only
proposing to repeal four words in rsa
175 section 1.
republicans have brought this bill
before
two to three times it's simply an
attempt to remove a state mandate saying
that convenience stores that sell
beer wine or tobacco also have to carry
three thousand dollars worth of dusty
cans of spam and eight dollar boxes of
cheerios and fruit loops and
and we probably all heard from
constituents at some point when somebody
asks
why do you have a frozen loaf of
bread sitting in the icebox
when nobody buys those things what we
heard from people who work at
convenience stores is the state tells
them that they have to have all that
stuff and what they do what they've told
me in
manchester and seabrook and hampton and
deerfield and other places i've been is
they say
they have to drive down to the
convenience store
and buy a couple of bags of these uh
groceries uh dusty cans of vienna
sausage and uh
and uh condensed milk and whatnot and
tabasco sauce and put it up on the
shelves and it sits there until it
reaches its expiration date and then
they throw it away and then they go back
to the
local grocery store and they they buy
more but they have to maintain
three thousand dollars of inventory the
rule doesn't say
that you have to sell three thousand
dollars worth it doesn't say that you
have to sell anything
that anyone wants to buy in fact the
people the convenience stores said the
opposite they said that they don't want
to carry anything
that people would buy because if
somebody bought the eight dollar box of
fruit loops they would have to drive
down to the the
local grocery store and buy another
eight dollar buck another box of fruit
loops and put an eight dollar price tag
on it we heard this over and over and
over again we heard this all over the
state
it's not
it's not that every single convenience
store is burdened by this but a lot of
them are the republican platform
specifically says
one remove barriers to business
formation so it's a republican platform
bill and number two minimize business
regulations permits licenses and
paperwork
we were finally told
uh during the executive session or we
were told during the hearing that there
were food deserts in new hampshire and
so i asked about that we finally heard
at the executive session that one of the
food deserts that they were referring to
was the city of manchester i used to
live in manchester i lived there for
years they were
one of the great things about manchester
is you can go out almost any time day or
night for a walk uh if you're armed it's
gotten kind of dangerous
i mean
not to not to be glib but the murder
rate went up while i was living there
it did it went to 12 murders a year
the house will be in order that's why i
bought a gun
okay anyway
i'm just saying you could go out in
manchester and you could buy food day or
night sorry to get off topic mr speaker
representative the representative that
that i i truly believe that that past
comment was out of line
okay i like i say i apologize for making
that comment i was going off topic
but but the point is that in the city of
manchester you there's no food desert
you can go walk anywhere and buy food
anytime day or night
so i felt that this byzantine rule we've
introduced the bill a couple of times
before
in both cases uh the vast majority of
republicans on commerce committee voted
to repeal this in both previous cases
the vast majority of republicans on the
floor of the house voted to repeal this
i don't see any reason to do a refer for
interim study what are you going to
study if we're only talking about
repealing four
four words in statute and we know that
when you repeal four words the remaining
words in rsa 175 section 1 would be in
place so i'm asking you to press the the
red button so that we can pass the
measure
jail recognizes representative hunt
speak for the committee report oh
representative hunt is waving off
motion before us on house bill 2 20 45
is majority report of interim study are
you ready for the question
although
mr speaker
has anyone signed up to do pis on this
there are if there's a division or a
roll call and i haven't heard one oh i
thought i asked for a division i'll just
do a voice vote i'm fine
division
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
division
um
this has this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for a parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you mr speaker and i'm uh
apologize again for uh bringing up the
ryzen uh
crime in manchester um that was not on
topic at all
uh mr speaker if i know that
not only existing convenience stores but
any proposed convenience stores would
have to comply with this mandate to
carry three thousand dollars worth of
you know dusty cans of everything and
boxes of fruit loops and if i know that
the republican party has always stood
for less regulation less red tape less
bureaucracy
and reducing the burden on business and
if i know that the biggest objection
that was raised by the other side was
that new convenience stores might open
up if this restriction is lifted which i
i think that we're supposed to be a
business friendly state and uh that's
about 70 percent of our our state's tax
burden comes from business taxes that we
want more businesses moving here and
creating jobs yes it's a
would i then press the red button
and so another motion can be made
chair recognized representation for
parliamentary inquiry represent is
waving off
this is a division vote
on the question is on house bill 245
majority
report of interim study
this division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button of your
opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative abrami represented
burststein
representative bouchard
representative
representative freitas
representative bill nelson
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
292 voting yay 62 voting a the committee
reports adopted
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs which was referred
house bill 472 act relative to
retroactive denials of previously paid
claims continue considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in
expediential legislation jeffrey greeson
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
senator constant van houghton for the
minority of the committee
the chair
recognizes senator van holten to speak
against the committee report
i'm here sir
a3
mr speaker
i rise in opposition to the pending
motion of an expedient to legislate on
house bills 472.
h.b 472 known as a clawback bill
deals with the retroactive denial of
accident and health insurance claims
such denial occurs after a patient has
been treated
and an insurer has paid the claim filed
by the health care provider
yet the patient was not covered by that
insurer at the time of treatment
the health care provider likely did
check and confirm the patient's coverage
by that insurer
yet due to a change of employment or if
insurance for example
the patient was not actually covered by
that insurance insurer at that time of
payment treatment excuse me at that time
of treatment
the insurance provider having already
paid the claim
would then claw back the payment amount
from the health care provider and by
current law has 12 months to do so
in that 12 months
the health care provider may have paid
mortgage utilities whatever bills
only to possibly lose some of the income
that was earned and spent
this can be especially devastating to a
health care practitioner in a solo or
small practice
the insurance provider though likely has
greater staff and resources and should
be able to find the payment error in
less than a year
you will likely hear that the time
period for denial of previously paid
claims was reduced from 18 months to 12
a session ago
that is true
and the change was in recognition of the
unfairness of a long period for an
insurance clawback
a full year is still simply a very long
time during which an insurance provider
is allowed to take a payment back from a
healthcare provider
a healthcare provider who with due
diligence and checking beforehand
provided services
and of course the health care provider
is then faced with attempting to track
down the party liable
for payment of those services that may
have been rendered more than a year
before
hp 472 if passed would shorten the
period for such retroactive denial to
six months
now especially with covert further
exacerbating our health care
and creating and multiplying mental
health care issues especially among
children
a 12-month claw back period has the
potential to contribute to health care
providers leaving their fields or
leaving small practices
or even changing to self-pay no
insurance accepted practices
passing hb 472 can be part of an easy
and fair fix
in reference to this bill the house
calendar states quote
none other than the sponsor of this bill
claimed any need to further reduce the
time end quote
however on just the blue sheet alone
there were
239 side ins in support of passage of hb
472 which reduces the time to six months
there is a need for this bill's passage
i ask that this body vote no on the
pending itl motion
in order to allow another motion to be
made thank you
chair recognizes representative greeson
to speak for the committee report thank
you mr speaker mr speaker and members of
the house the majority of the commerce
committee has determined that house bill
472 is inexpedient to legislate because
rsa 415 section 6i was recently amended
to reduce the allowable period for a
retroactive denial from 18 months down
to 12 months and this change
just took effect january 1st 2019
no one provided any compelling reason
for any further changes
and the 12-month period for retroactive
uh
denials
matches what is allowed in all the
states that surrounds new hampshire and
there just really is no need for
any further reduction in the clawback
time so given that there is no
compelling need to revisit this period
for retroactive denials the majority
recommends house bill 472 be found
inexpedient to legislate thank you
question before us on house bill 472 the
majority report have been expedient to
legislate
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it from the
is adopted
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 473 enact
establishing a renter's insurance
notification requirement having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator
bonningham for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator christy bartlett for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
bartlett to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker and colleagues i come before
you to ask if you understand your
homeowners or renters insurance policies
i'm speaking against the itl motion from
the commerce committee
i'm a retired insurance property and
casualty underwriter
you know here's the truth
when i was working and went to a party
or some gathering
and someone asked me what i did for a
living as soon as i said i was in
insurance it was often a silence and a
change of subject
however
by the end of the event so often i would
be approached with a question about
insurance
because lots of people don't understand
it
sometimes the argument is that you don't
need it until you need it
this is a republican-sponsored bill
including sponsors from salem
this bill came before us last term as
well it was brought before us after two
separate
devastating fires in their town
the apartments in which these families
lived were total losses and none of the
residents had renters insurance to cover
the loss of their belongings
or the additional living expense the
additional cost to live elsewhere
we heard testimony both years from the
sponsors that the tenants didn't even
know about renters insurance
this is a terrible experience not only
for the tenants but also for the
landlords and the town
these families lost everything and had
nowhere to go
who helps them when something like this
happens
oh yes the first couple of weeks there
may be
gracious and generous townspeople who
might have a spaghetti dinner or put out
jars in local stores to try to do
something for them
there might even be a gofundme page on
facebook
however when there are so many without
homes or belongings these families will
have to rely on the towns and cities
human services departments
in small towns this is very difficult on
the budgets and other residents
as these families look for a new place
to live can you imagine that they need
to continue to work and go to school at
the same time
or maybe not
i'm wondering if most people in this
room understand that a landlord's
insurance
does not and cannot cover the tenant's
property uh the member will suspend for
a minute
it's getting awful loud in here we've
asked before
if you're going to have a conversation
take it out into the hallway the member
has a right to be heard as all members
do thank you
thank you mr speaker
i'm wondering if most people in this
room understand that a landlord's
insurance cannot does not and cannot
cover the tenant's property
unless there is gross negligence on the
landlord's part where there would be
liability
the landlord has no insurable interest
in the tenant's property
i can't buy an insurance policy to cover
your property
the landlord is also not responsible for
finding the tenants another place to
live
or to pay for the additional living
expense such as hotel or restaurant
costs
this bill is very simple
all it would be all it would do would be
to notify a tenant in any written rental
agreement that the landlord cannot
provide renters insurance
and that they may want to purchase it
for themselves
that's it
there are no mandates just a very simple
statement
as most rentals are written agreements
these days and there's a great deal of
detail to protect the landlord in each
agreement
this is just a clause that would protect
both parties to the contract
i'm guessing that some of you present
either own real estate property or may
rent an apartment i also would like to
think that each of you who is a landlord
cares about your tenants
and in the event of a catastrophic fire
water damage claim wind damage or other
kind of loss what would you do
renters insurance is not an expensive
policy
nothing like the cost of insuring a
building or a home
for about the cost of a couple of
coffees per month
tenants would have peace of mind knowing
that they would have coverage in the
event of a loss
this bill would simply notify the tenant
that they should consider purchasing
renters insurance
oh i know the argument might be
that it's the responsibility of the
tenant to understand their exposure but
there's no easy way for people to
educate anyone about insurance
if it was right in the rental agreement
the renters would at least know they'd
been told
and if they chose not to buy it then
that's their decision
please consider voting against the
committee's recommendations so another
motion can be brought forward and thanks
for caring
the chair recognizes representative hunt
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
so this was an interesting one for the
commerce committee because uh in the
past we have been the ones that
required on purchases sales agreements
when you buy a property
that there are some set pieces in there
are required to be disclosed
so we tro we took this bill as sort of
like okay how do we get that disclosure
occurred a purchase sale agreement is a
written document that has to be you know
done ahead of time
and there is a form by the mls that that
is a standard form for purchases of
training
so we then went about to see was there a
form out there
for rentals
was there a landlord was there
association was anything about we could
not find one
so in lack of finding any proper form to
have someone
have this sentence inserted
it then comes down to
how many people really truly don't know
that in new hampshire
you don't have to buy auto insurance
in new hampshire
you don't have to buy
tenant insurance
we don't
make statues trying to tell people to
educate people
frankly i thought this was an incredible
sales opportunity for every landlord to
at least or for insurance agents to get
the landlords to hand them a form and
say you should get insurance we passed
legislation last year to allow
storage use storage buildings to
actually pass out a little pamphlet and
urge people to get insurance for those
storage facilities the proper way of
doing this is let the free market solve
this problem we do not need this
legislation
question where
oh
question for the
does a member yield to a question sure
remember yields you may inquire
okay
i have a very very simple question for
your very complex explanation which is
would it cost
the owner of the rental property owner
more than a penny
to hand his rental
person
the renter
a piece of paper that simply says
i am not responsible for your
possessions
so
if you want insurance
that's your choice
uh well here's the thing
the problem with the bill is it says
only if there is a written lease
so i'm not sure i want to be able to try
to incentivize landlords not to have a
written lease so they don't have to be
worried about what state laws they
needed to write into this lease or not
lease
the issue is there's nothing stopping a
landlord now to inform
consumers inform their tenants that they
need to get insurance just like we all
know that we probably need auto
insurance even though that's not
mandatory either
follow-up
does the member yield to another
question
remember it does not yield
the
question before us on house bill 473 is
the majority report of inexpediting to
legislate
are you ready for the question
division has been called members take
their seats
hello
division
you you should have my name there we do
so
oh
a division has been requested so this is
a division vote the house will come to
water
the chair recognizes representative
mccleary
for a parliamentary in question
uh thank you mr chairman uh it's
actually chris mcaleer appreciate it
uh mr speaker
if i know that people have perceptions
different
both positive and negative based on
certain clues
and how they interpret these clues
would i not give you an example of that
right now
now i don't want anybody to raise their
hand
but how many smokers do we have out
there that's that's that isn't part of a
parliamentary inquiry i'll give you
dollars to donuts
that there are more ex-smokers here
than there are current smokers in fact i
myself have quit smoking several hundred
represent representative this is a
problem this is a parliamentary inquiry
not a speech
yes sir
uh if i know
if i know that one of the small but
nevertheless key components
of a very successful campaign
to discourage smoking
was when the u.s surgeon general managed
to get a very scary
warning on the sides of cigarette
packages
warning of the dangers
over time some people actually took the
heed of this
representative
you're making a speech not a
parliamentary inquiry
well what we know and what i know is
that that was very very effective in
reducing smoking a matter of fact over
the last three decades
smoking has gone down three
a lot until last year
when actually smoking went up
clearly people became informed
of the dangers of smoking they became
educated
smokers reacted and many of them quit
mr speaker point of order
if i know that the vast majority
representative i i i realize
you probably haven't done too many pi's
no i have not
you're not really doing a parliamentary
inquiry
so i i would ask that maybe you wrap it
up
i will wrap it up
my point is this
i'm sorry
if i know
that the majority of tenants do not have
homeowners insurance and never heard of
homeowners insurance
wouldn't it make sense that we make a
provision for them to know
i don't think that that's being
heavy-handed
i
i know that's not being heavy-handed
i wrap it up i hope that you will
press the red button as i will
on this note thank you
the chair recognizes representative hunt
for a parliamentary inquiry
house will be in order
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i like
to support the commerce committee will i
now vote green
the question before us is on house bill
the majority report of inexpensive
legislate
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative shirtless
representative moran are you here
representative timothy smith
representative to me
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
190 voting yay 166 voting a a committee
report is adopted
mr speaker
what i remember rise i'd like to make a
request that we uh put the comments from
the debate on house bill 473 in the
record that would serve as instruction
to
potential less ease
that homeowners insurance does not cover
renters insurance has been stated
numerous times so that could therefore
cover the objective okay okay
yeah you want it you want to put the
comments in the permanent journal yes
sir
we need to take a vote on it there is an
objection
all those in favor of placing the
comments and then
okay
the motion is to put the comments in the
permanent journal all those in favor say
aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
a division has been called
members take their seats only members in
the chamber can vote
nobody else can come in
the motion is to put the comments
473 in the permanent journal
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
one second wait a minute
should be open now you're all set should
be all set
representatives alicea ammon ordnae
cohen commtoys
dolan di lorenzo
ford espitia
ellison
edwards
i've got your vote representative
ententine you're all set
crosstalk
representatives partial
rhodes representative petrigno
representative porter
representative oxenam
representative tabarisch
representative vann
representative welch
[Music]
so
representative marjorie smith
[Music]
also
if
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
153 voting yay 182 voting nay
the marks are not being printed
mr speaker
on 473 representative baxter declared a
conflict of interest and did not
participate in the vote
for what reason to remember arise
i i have a question mr speaker since
this is a new year could you remind us
what the cost is per page when we put
remarks printed into the journal
do we do we have an approximate cost per
page
no
all right thank you
oh my goodness
smith
committee it's getting awful noisy
mr speaker
for what reason does it memorize to make
a motion
stage of motion
motion to special order hb 50 52 and 54.
to win
to be the next order of business
do you wish to speak to your motion i do
i understand the motion is debatable so
i will speak to my motion
hb 50 52 and 54
address
the
decennial redistricting that needs to
occur every 10 years in this state
by virtue of the name
of the committee it is at the end of the
calendar
and i am extremely concerned that as
many members as possible have an
opportunity to vote on those motions
given their importance
i am very concerned about the weather
regardless of any day and forecast
coming up and i have had it expressed to
me
by a committee member that they are
concerned about their ability to attend
the next two days and i would like to
give all of my committee members the
opportunity to vote on these motions
the question is to special order house
bill 50
52 and 54.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
those oppose nay
the eyes have it
the emotion is adopted
uh can i
can the house come to order
before we get into the next bills i want
to let you know what our tentative plans
are
i'm planning on going
between five and six tonight
no later than six
um
i just want to remind everybody
that
we are not making that good a progress
uh
so it looks like it's going to be
indeterminal that we are going to have
to be here on friday
uh i don't want to keep anybody later
than
six seven o'clock
and um at the pace we're going we're not
gonna make it so i um
i'm i'm i'm hoping that we can get out
of here between five and six tonight
maybe five and six tomorrow night
and just hope and pray that the weather
isn't too bad on friday
i i don't see how we can finish at the
pace we're going
state your question
um thank you mr speaker i i just i think
it might benefit the members to know are
we under any obligation to vacate this
space by any particular time on friday
no
so if need be we can in terms of the
facility we can stay till 10 pm if we
have to if we have to thank you and i
hope you all like pizza if we have to do
that
mr speaker
oh yes
a1
i uh
i shouldn't say this because i'm on the
wrong side of this i guess
but there are people who are not here
today who might want to be here tomorrow
to vote on redistricting
and i feel very badly about that that
they cannot be that's off okay
we've already taken the vote
representative
i know he's taking the vote but
maybe we could reconsider
are you me
are you making that motion
yes i'd like to make that motion to
reconsider for the people who couldn't
be here today and knew that that
particular
item was going to be at the end of the
calendar
member members
will come to order please we have a
motion
speaker parliamentary inquiry please
state your inquiry
doesn't it require a member voting on
the prevailing side of a question to
make the motion to reconsider and i
listened very very carefully mr speaker
and i heard nobody from the other side
of the room passed about here vote in
favor of the previous motion i believe
it's out of order well seeing it was a
voice vote representative she did say
that she
did vote on the prevailing side
so the motion be the question before us
is reconsideration
on
the motion
of special ordering house bill 50 52 and
54. are you ready for the
who called the division
division has been called this will be a
division vote
members members take their seats
[Music]
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats this will be a roll
call vote
[Music]
so
thank
all right the house will come to water
members take your seats
it's continually get louder and louder
in here and members are not being able
to be heard or hear
so i'm asking you
to be courteous to your fellow
colleagues
and if you're gonna have a conversation
take it outside
the motion before us is on
reconsideration this is going to be a
roll call vote
okay
if you're in favor you're going to press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative perez
representative pimental
representative perez cut
okay thank you
is representative van still here
representative vann not man sorry
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
35 voting a
316 voting may reconsideration fails
mr speaker
i'm at d
one
hp 50 is brought to being brought to
consideration
i make the motion from the floor
that hp 50 be tabled for further
off you haven't consideration stated
what the situation is so we don't have a
building for us
i need to read the report first
representative before you can get up and
make a motion to table
i'll wait here patiently sir
majority of the committee on special
committee on redistricting to wish was
referred house bill 50.
an act of portioning state
representative districts having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
representative carol maguire for the
majority of the committee
it's getting awful noisy
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment senate paul bergeron from the
minority of the committee
the question
before the house is the majority
committee amendment
two
two seven four h printed in house record
48 pages 50-58
mr speaker is it now time
for me to make my motion from the floor
the chair recognizes the member to make
a motion i move to place hp 50 on the
table
who requested the roll call
representative
is that sufficiently second silver has
requested a rolls call is that
officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats
roko
so
mr speaker
oh
yes representative yes uh i have a
parliamentary inquiry if i could
i state your inquiry i'm sorry
could you explain to us what the
ramifications are of this tabling
motion i'm sure i'm sure somebody
speaking will
tabling's not debatable sir
parliamentary inquiries
no that was my inquiry just could the
speaker explain
what the consequences are
of tabling this motion
i i believe that it will be
delineated in the in the parliamentary
inquiry by representative griffin
as speaker i don't
wish to make any comments on what would
happen or wouldn't happen with a piece
of legislation i don't believe that's my
place thank you sir
mr speaker
for what member member rise a question
to the speaker
mr speaker if this tabling motion passes
am i correct that it will take a
majority to take it off the table and
then it will take two-thirds to pass it
no
no it will be a majority for both
yes thank you mr speaker
the question before us is the table in
motion on
house bill 50.
this is a roll call vote members will
take their seats
is there going to be a parliamentary
inquiry from the member that requested
the tabling motion
chair recognizes representative allegro
for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
there are a number of issues
if i know
that stand before this house
and amongst them
are the redistricting bills
everybody must understand that a
redistricting bill
that's
i'm sorry i stand corrected sorry
if i knew that this was going to give us
the opportunity
to review these bills and also address
some other very important issues in the
house
would i press green
to table this bill temporarily thank you
chair recognizes representative griffin
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill is an important constitutional item
that must be addressed or to go forward
would render this representative body
unconstitutional it is a matter that
must be addressed and if i know that to
be true mr speaker would i now press the
red button to allow this matter to go
forward
the question before us
is the tabling motion on house bill 50.
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative conley
representative dolan representative
dodge
representative
elliott
representative gottling representative
harley
representative tucker
representative mcbride
representative tucker you're not
registering could you come see me please
oh my gosh
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
so
i am going to
exercise my privilege and vote
yeah no
no
making it a tie so the motion fails
so the motion
to lay on the table fails
[Music]
the house will be in order so we're back
to the majority amendment there's no
debate on the majority amendment there
is a pi however
what is what is what is before us is the
majority amendment 2274-h
printed in house record 48 pages 50-58
are you ready for the question
all those
roll call has been requested i'm done by
sure is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote on the majority amendment
[Music]
members will take their seats
the motion before us is the majority
amendment
on house bill 50. this is a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
thompson
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
want to know that this the amendment to
this
bill would create a change that would
not be in the interest of my
constituents and would create another
district that would not serve coast
county would i press the red button
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
mcguire for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
if i know that this amendment
meets the constitutional requirements
of
fair representation
and if i know that it balances
the desires and the needs to have each
town to have its own district with the
requirement that every person has an
equal vote
would i then press the green button
the motion before us is the on house
bill 50 is the majority amendment
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
you
so
[Music]
representative acton
representative diane kelly
representative langley
it's it's working
representative plett
representative vale
you're all set representative
if all members president had the
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
186 voting
170 voting a the majority amendment is
adopted
bill's on second reading and opened a
further amendment
representative bergeron moves
2277h
printed in house record 48 pages 58
through 70.
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron
thank you mr speaker i'm at microphone
a1
during public input sessions in all 10
counties the message from the public was
consistent and clear
provide each board in town their own
representative
if it has the population required to
support it
keep cities together in base and
floaterial districts
and when multi-town districts are
required
base those districts on communities of
interest
creating state representative districts
for towns that have a sufficient
population for their own representatives
is a redistricting requirement under the
state constitution
the minority amendment before you now
keeps those as
prior uh
important criteria in the development of
its plan
the amendment increases the number of
districts in carroll county from eight
to ten
as a result instead of one seven pound
full terial won eleven town floaterial
the proposal creates three smaller full
terials
the minority plan before you gives
bolton barrel its own state
representative district
the majority proposal puts bolton
borough in a floaterial
in cheshire county the minority
amendment provides single town
representation to four communities
chesterfield hinsdale rindgen winchester
twice the number provided in the
majority amendment
virtually everyone at the ten county
hearings wanted more local
representation not less
the minority plan avoided the use of
giant floaterial districts
some of which in the majority proposal
combine as many as six keen wards with a
number of smaller towns
in the majority plan the electoral power
of the keen wards will effectively
preclude the smaller towns from any
effective representation in these
chambers
as there is little community of interest
between the city wards and the towns
in the minority plan however five towns
get their own representatives
roxbury ridge winchester hinsdale and
chesterfield
in the republican plan
only two towns get their own
representatives
the majority plan violates the
constitution in coast county
by denying berlin its own dedicated
representatives despite having adequate
population for its own district
berlin was entitled to three seats in
the house based on its population
and its population was well within the
acceptable range of deviation for those
three seats
the minority amendment complies with the
new hampshire constitution while
maintaining the exact same deviation as
the majority plan
in grafton county the minority plan
offers a lower range of deviation
it creates only one floaterial district
not two as appears in my majority
proposal
and littleton would share a district
with only one other town
whereas the majority plan puts littleton
in a six town district
in hillsborough county
the minority plan would ensure that the
city of manchester received the number
of representatives it's entitled to
based on its population
manchester is entitled to 33.58
representatives
34 rounded up 33 if rounded down
the majority plan however cuts that even
further and only gives them 32.
the proposal of the minority increases
the number of towns with their own base
districts including pelham and new
ipswich
and the largest floaterial in the
minority plan includes four towns
the majority's plan's
largest full terial includes nine
for merrimack county the minority
amendment provides single town
representation to eight communities
and in rockingham county the largest
number of reps in the floaterial
district is six
while the majority proposes a floaterial
district of ten representatives
in conclusion the minority amendment
prioritizes keeping cities together in
state representative districts
giving each town their own
representative if they had sufficient
population to for in a district and when
it's not possible
to create geographically small districts
in order to create the most fair and
constitutional state representative
district map as possible thank you mr
speaker
the chair recognizes
representative turcotte to speak for the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
hb 50 is a statewide redistricting plan
and as a statewide plan it is impossible
to achieve perfection
our own new hampshire supreme court has
acknowledged this stating quote
ultimately part two
article 11 cannot be considered in
isolation
and it sets forth only some of several
constitutional criteria
that a redistricting plan must satisfy
in 2001 the
court has further explained
a balance must be drawn
trade-offs must be made
the majority of the committee has
created a map that has increased the
number of towns wards and places with
their own representatives
while falling within
constitutionally permission uh
permissible deviation
the majority has voted avoided the
unnecessary creation of large
floaterials while striking a balance to
avoid the arbitrary favoring of one town
over another
the minority map fails to achieve these
same objectives and instead favor
certain districts for the purpose of
artificially enhancing cherry-picked
numbers
the majority plan for hb 50 meets all of
the constitutional requirements while
maintaining 400 representatives in the
house as was unanimously
decided by the special redistricting
committee
the majority plan will constitutionally
and fairly represent the residents of
new hampshire for the next 10 years
the next decade
i therefore ask that you support the
majority of the redistricting committee
and reject the minority amendment
thank you mr speaker
so who's going to call for a roll call
i'm sure this is going to be roll called
a roll call has been requested that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members will take their seats this will
be a roll call vote
uh
rocole
so
members will take their seats this would
be a roll call vote
so
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes
representative weber for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that when i looked at the maps
contrary to what you have just
well let me start again if i know that
when the minority
made their plan
contrary to what was just represented
represented
we took as our first principle to try
and get the most local representation
possible
irrespective of whether
that would damage an incumbent be it
democratic or republican we tried to
follow the principles that we hoped an
independent redistricting commission
would follow
if i know that in looking at the maps
the minorities submitted
that have become this amendment
that
they result in smaller floaterials
and more local representation
than the majority maps would i now
press the green button
to support the minority amendment thank
you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative
turcotte for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know the minority amendment
arbitrarily favors certain districts to
the detriment of others
and if i also know that the majority map
is constitutional and provides fair
representation
to the people of new hampshire
and if i also know that the majority
redistricting bill is superior to the
minorities redistricting redistricting
proposal
would i now support the majority of the
redistricting committee
by pressing the red
button
the question is on
house the question is on house bill 50
the minority committee amendment
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're approached you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
representative rogers
representative sanborn
uh you i can't vote for you you have to
[Music]
come on up
so
it's just registered
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
representative tauscher are you in here
cancel
representative tauscher if you can oh
there we go thank you
house we'll tend to this state of the
road
165 voting yes 192 voting nay minority
commitment committee amendment fails
the question now before the house is
house bill 50
as amended by the
[Music]
majority committee amendment
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron to speak against the committee
amendment
in the bill
mr speaker i'll just summarize what i
said previously
since many of my remarks were also
directed to the majority report
during public input sessions in all ten
counties a message from the public was
consistent and clear
provide each ward in town their own
representative that has the population
required to support it
keep cities together and base floaterial
districts
and when multi-town districts are
required base those districts on
communities of interest
the republican majority plan fails to do
so and i would encourage the members to
vote against it
the chair recognizes representative
mcguire to speak for the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
as we said when discussing the amendment
is that
can
it's getting awful noisy again
as we said when we were discussing the
amendment
this bill as amended balances the
federal and state constitutional
requirements for redistricting
they must meet both the federal and the
state requirements
one
part of our constitution part two
article 11
says when the population of any town or
ward according to the last federal
census is within a reasonable deviation
from the ideal population for one or
more representative seats the town award
shall have its own district of one or
more representative seats
we heard that
hundreds of times from people around the
state
but most of them did not go on to read
the rest of that paragraph
which says the apportionment shall not
deny any other town or award membership
in one non-floaterial representative
district
when any town ward or unincorporated
place has fewer than the number of
inhabitants necessary to entitle it to
one representative the legislature shall
form those towns wards or unincorporated
places into representative districts
which contain a sufficient number of
inhabitants to title each district so
formed to one or more representatives
for the entire district
informing the districts the boundaries
of towns awards and an incorporate
unincorporated places shall be preserved
and contiguous
the excess number of inhabitants of
districts may be added to the excess
number of inhabitants of other districts
to form at large or floaterial districts
conforming to acceptable deviations
so it's not as simple as if you have 3
400 rep
residents you have your own state rep
the state supreme court has stated that
this cannot be considered in isolation
and and that there are several
constitutional criteria that the
redistricting plan must satisfy
perfection is not possible and a balance
must be drawn
so the majority map makes reasonable and
appropriate trade-offs
not arbitrarily favoring certain
districts to the detriment of others
we as a committee
unanimously agreed to have 400
representatives
we allocated those 400 representatives
to the county so that no district will
cross a county line
and then we
develop districts
meeting the
normal definition of reasonable
deviation which is 10 percent
all districts are contiguous there's no
town boundaries broken every town is in
a non-floaterial district
and
that
we assume that the cities would divide
their awards for equal populations which
is
their responsibility
and we tried to create single town
districts
but as much as possible without
depriving another town of its fair
representation
where possible we kept cities within
their boundaries and did not share
districts to the adjoining towns
and then we used literal districts to
make sure the deviations came out
correct
these maps are constitutional and they
fairly represent the people of new
hampshire
we hope that you will support them
and vote green thank you
so who's going to make the motion for a
roll call
which i know was coming
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members will take your seats
where are those
members will be in their seats this is a
roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
espedia for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that granite theaters gave
clear direction at the redistricting
committee's public input sessions
requesting compact house districts that
keep cities together and provide local
representations to communities of
sufficient population
if i know that hb 50 as amended rejects
that public input needlessly lumping
cities in with other communities and
stacking towns into mega districts with
no rational bases
if i want to comply with the new
hampshire constitution and provide the
smallest most representative districts
possible but i now press the red button
to vote no on the committee report
the chair recognizes representative
stephen smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this plan meets all the
constitutional requirements it's
certainly an improvement over what we
have now creating more single
municipality districts
mr speaker if i know we even
incorporated elements from both parties
into the majority committee amendment
would i press the green button
the question before us on house bill 50
is
the majority
ought to pass motion as amended with the
majority committee report
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative delemus
representative to parish
so
agreed
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote 186 voting yay 168 voting may
the committee report is adopted
speaker
does what what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker having voted on the
prevailing side i remove reconsideration
and urge my colleagues to vote now
the motion before us is reconsideration
on house bill 50.
are you ready for the
the question
has been requested
uh all members take their seats the
division has been requested
representative rice requests a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it looks like it's sufficiently seconded
rocole
[Music]
i think
the question before us is the
reconsideration on house bill 50.
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button
wait a minute
minor technical difficulty
okay
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
several members
representative ames
representative ammon
representative conley
representative lange
you're also representative lane
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
167 voting 188 voting a reconsideration
fails
for what reason does a member rise thank
you mr speaker i request that the debate
from hb 50 be printed in the permanent
journal please
without objection the debate will be
printed in the permanent journal
okay
majority of the committee on
special
committee on redistricting to which was
referred house bill 52
an act of portioning congressional
districts having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment senate
bob lynn from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment
representative marjorie smith for the
minority of the committee mr speaker
d1
what member reason does the member rise
uh moved hb 52 be laid on the table and
ask for a roll call vote
the motion is to lay hb 52 on the table
this is a roll call vote members will
take their seats
row
ah
i did not
uh there was a motion there was a motion
to lay it on the table in a roll call
vote
i mistakenly did not ask if it was
seconded
is there enough seconds on
that yes there's more than enough
seconds
members will take their seats this is a
roll call vote members must be in their
oh seats good for him
do you plan on doing a parliamentary
inquiry
the motion on house bill 52
is to lay it on the table
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
representative cushman
representative elliott
representative marsh
walmart balmer's president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
177 voting 178 voting may the tabling
motion fails
for the record i did not vote on this
one
majority
emerging amendment yeah
the majority committee amendment is 2271
h
printed in house record 48 pages 70
through 73.
the chair recognizes
a division has been requested members
will take their seats we're just doing
parliamentary inquiries
division
members will take their seats
sooner everybody gets in their seats the
sooner we can be done
the motion before us is on the majority
committee amendment this is a division
vote the chair recognizes representative
marjorie smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i
knew that in 2018
the well-respected national organization
did a
thorough evaluation of every state's
congressional district
and when they destroy the map that would
most favor the democratic party in the
state of new hampshire
they drew the exact same map
that the republican majority on the
special
committee on
redistricting drew this exact same app
and mr speaker if i knew
that and if i were a republican
in the new hampshire legislature in 2021
i would not want to settle for half a
loaf
and therefore i would oppose
the majority amendment on house bill 52
and would then vote
red
on the majority amendment in order to
consider an amendment which might make
it possible
for my party the republican party in
this case or the democratic party to win
both seats
i would press the red button
the house will be in order
it's getting awful noisy again
the chair recognizes representative
barbara griffin for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this
committee amendment before this body
addresses a change that has to be made
due to population changes over the last
10 years and mr speaker
if i know
that in fact the map that is presented
by this amendment is not
the most partisan passable map that
there is and apparently some people
don't know how to draw maps very well
and finally
mr speaker
if i am aware
that the map before
this body will in this amendment 2271
will provide for legal
state and federal constitutional
representation
over the next 10 years would i now press
the green button to support the
committee amendment
the question before us is the majority
committee amendment on house bill 52
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative ellis
representative barbara griffin
representative perez
representative wrong
so
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
184 voting yay 171 voting nay the
majority of the committee report is
adopted
amendment
all right second meeting further
amendment this is the second reading
open to further amendment this is the
minority amendment 2 2 4 5 h
printed in house record 48 pages 67
through 70.
marjorie representative marjorie smith
moves adoption and is recognized to
speak for in favor of her amendment
thank you very much mr speaker
basically since 1880
the two
district
maps i mean the two districts for
congress
i'm just waiting for quiet
my mother told me never to speak when
other people were speaking
the sooner everyone can take their seats
and take their conversations outside we
can get through these bills
thank you mr speaker for your courtesy
um
from 1880 until now in new hampshire
there have been two congressional
districts and the basic map has stayed
the same
in the second district republicans won
71 times and democrats
15 in the last 86
elections
the first district changed hands in six
of the last eight elections with
incumbents losing in five of those races
new hampshire has predominantly leaned
republican
state elections have frequently been
purple with a healthy party mixture of
governor state house senate and u.s
house and senate
new hampshire voters every two years
vote for the candidate they prefer
without necessarily following
party lines
under
federal and state
constitutional and
legal requirements
we need to have
two equal districts from the current
census
for the new hampshire congressional
seats
we were off by 18 000 votes
citizens so once the new census figures
came back all we had to do
was move nine thousand people from the
first district
into the second district
we didn't have to really shake
everything up we didn't have to change
things in any dramatic way
moving nine thousand people
would give us two districts with equal
population
and in fact that is what the minority
amendment does it moves only nine
thousand people from the first district
into the second
this differs from the amendment that at
the moment
this house has passed but there's still
time to correct the mistake
by they have moved about 25
of the total population of the state
from one district
to another
for no
logical reason
in two days of public hearings only one
person
testified in favor of the majority
amendment
and his thoughtful reasoned presentation
was that this amendment would help the
incumbents gain seniority in washington
and
and he thought that was important
it is important if what you believe is
protecting incumbency
it's not important if what you believe
is making sure that citizens have the
right every two years to choose the
person they want to lead
that is the strength of the new
hampshire public
uh political system
in the house in the senate and the
executive council and the governorship
voters are able to decide every two
years whether or not to keep it in
incumbent in the u.s house it's the same
thing unfortunately we have no control
over the length of the u.s senate term
that's six years we can't do anything
about it but in new hampshire we like to
vote for our elected officials every two
years it's unique in the nation and it's
one of our great
strengths
every candidate should be able to
approach an election on a level playing
field
the majority on the committee stated
clearly
that their goal was to tilt that playing
field
please support the minority amendment
that protects the rights of all new
hampshire voters to have a fair
opportunity
to color our state
red
blue or purple
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
the courtesy of letting me speak without
standing up
chair recognizes representative berry
thank you mr speaker
i'm specifically addressing some of the
complaints raised by the minority of the
committee
the minority moved one town that town
happened to be one of the most
republican towns in the state why is
that important mr speaker because while
the minority of the committee speaks of
fairness of the current districts they
have won 90 of the contests under the
current map
that is not purple mr speaker one drop
of red and nine drops of blue is not
purple it's just blue
furthermore mr speaker
the majority map did a better job of
preserving
shared sewer and water systems
shared police and fire departments and
regional planning committees which are
crucial for receiving federal funds
the minority many the minority amendment
the minority map proposed only does a
better job of preserving public health
regions to address their claim of moving
people into a new seat mr speaker when
we draw maps
there's no such thing as looking at the
current map you draw new districts every
time and if one was to look at the
original versions of cd1 and cd2 as the
minority said which was driven in 1880
you wouldn't recognize them today and in
fact there's been reports mr speaker
public reports that the original maps
were gerrymandered to dilute the
catholic vote which is why nashua and
manchester were originally separated i'm
not making that accusation today mr
speaker it was over 130 40 years ago but
people should be aware of that while
claims are being made
with that mr speaker i ask that you vote
no on this amendment and i request a
roll call vote
a roll call vote has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take this seat
[Music]
so
the motion before us is the minority
amendment on house bill 52.
the chair recognizes representative
expedia for a parliamentary inquiry
thanks mr speaker
if i know that we have had competitive
balanced congressional maps and if i
know that
a rewrite of the map is entirely
unnecessary as simple changes from this
amendment will keep these districts
competitive and if i know that this
amendment will keep a level playing
field and allow voters democrats
republicans and
independents alike to pick their
politicians and not the other way around
will i now push the green button to keep
our congressional map spare for another
10 years
the chair recognizes representative lynn
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you thank you mr speaker if if i
know
the reason stated uh earlier by uh my
colleague from manchester that uh the
the proposal in the republic in the uh
majority
uh does a better job of ensuring
first of all it meets constitutional
requirements and it does a better job of
ensuring that more people within the
state will be able to to choose the
representative to make the the choice
that they desire for representative
would i then
vote to
defeat the the
minority
and press the red button
the question before us is the minority
amendment on house bill 52
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
lined up
representative conley
representative
bill king
representative peterson
representative schultz
representative snow
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
167 167 voting 889 voting may
the minority committee report fails
we're on second reading and open to
further amendment
representative
abramson office floor amendment 2 301 h
it's
it was that was at the tables
you don't have seat pockets
chair recognizes
representative abramson
thank you mr speaker i was going to say
seat pockets but it's uh it's amendment
2301h which is not only available at the
table but it's been circulating around
the proposed
map that i've been trying to uh bring to
the special redistricting committee or
the idea that i've been trying to bring
to the special redistricting committee
i've not been able to make the meetings
but it's simply the idea that the
boundary line should be as short as
possible
and there are three reasons why you want
a boundary line as short as possible
what the map does in this case you just
have rockingham county stratford county
the city of nashua the city of
manchester where we are would be one
district joined by pelham litchfield and
hudson so that would be the lower
right-hand corner of the state
that proposed
district would give you the more compact
district and then the northern and
western parts of this the state would be
the other district
would be district 2.
the reason for doing that is
is going with the shortest boundary
possible number one
of all of the drawn up congressional
maps the ones that have been thrown out
by the courts
whether it was in
wisconsin ohio
north carolina
pennsylvania they've been long boundary
districts
courts have thrown out long boundary
time and again they very rarely survive
the second reason is
that the general public looks at long
boundary districts like the one proposed
in 2271 h
that has just been passed the majority
recommendation
and
they look at that and they feel like
it looks like gerrymandering
uh it looks unfair it looks like
somebody was playing games it looks like
somebody was drawing a line of spaghetti
around the state
now from from the inner district it
doesn't look like that but from the
outer district one member of this house
said that it looks like someone would
have to drive from nashua all the way to
the north country and then come down to
portsmouth and from the outside of the
state it looks like
it looks inappropriate it looks like
it's unfair
now i do agree
with the intent
of having a republican leaning district
and the democrat leaning district
having what what i called several years
ago proportional representation uh which
i suggested before i ever became a
member of the
uh this body
so i i do think that it you you are no
matter what kind of map you're going to
draw you're going to end up in a 50-50
state you're going to end up with one
congressional district that leans a
little republican and you're going to
have one that leans a little bit
democrat
however if we are are interested in
maintaining accountability of our
elected officials then we need to have
competitive districts
using dave's redistricting software
online which is a
powerful online software development
tool we can actually measure the
effectiveness and the quality of
proposed districts and this district
design
achieves a score of 83 on
competitiveness which is uh one of the
highest
not only one of the highest in the
country but it would be
better than any of the other proposals
that have been placed in front of us
there's there are other reasons to
support
uh
2301 over the other plans
and the benefit of course is with the
shortest boundary line you get lower
cost campaigns so when when you have
people campaigning for congress they
don't have to raise as much money from
special interest groups
most of the special interest money
pouring into new hampshire is pouring in
from out of state of course
and we want to have two representatives
in our delegation who are answerable
to us who are answerable to the voters
and you're not going to get that
answerability if they're having to raise
twice as much money
to campaign over a much larger area and
possibly having to run tv ads
in the expense of maine and
massachusetts markets which are which
are really expensive and that would be a
consequence of
uh the majority's proposed plan i don't
think that that was intended but that
would be one of the unintended side
effects
i think that the
going with shortest
shortest boundary possible
gives you some things more competitive
putting the boundary
as close to manchester as possible where
we have the va and we have a lot of
federal issues coming through manchester
and nashua
would give the voters who were along
that boundary line who are along this
corridor the 93 corridor would give them
uh
greater ability to maintain
accountability and it would be much
easier to vote out
members of congress who are not not
being responsive to the voters
so you would
according to software you would still
get a basically an r plus three district
and probably a d plus three district but
that's that's inevitable with any plan
that you have but i think it's having a
more competitive district
looks fairer it looks better it gives
the voters of this state more control
over who we have in congress
we've looked at the results of
other states that for various reasons
are stuck with either you know one
republican or one democrat or a group of
entrenched republicans and democrats and
the the results are not good their
members of congress are much much less
responsive to the concerns of the voters
and many of them don't even have uh town
hall meetings and don't even come back
to their district and some of them don't
even live in their district so i'm
asking members to
press the green button and support
amendment 2301 it would just carve out a
much smaller district or a much more
compact district in the lower right hand
corner of the state and the rest of the
state would be district 2.
chair recognize representative barry
uh yes mr speaker thank you um the
proposed maps creates a he talks about
the size of the districts the proposed
maps creates a cd2 that's significantly
larger and thus more expensive to
campaign in
but to address specifically he makes an
argument about the length of the
district mr chairman the aclu brought
forward a i believe it's a 42-page
document review reviewing the proposed
majorities maps and at no point did the
aclu raise a legal argument
against the majorities maps the
majorities maps has a population
deviation of 88 people and 89 people
respectively and it never divides a town
so we managed to get that low of a
deviation in a state of 1.377
million people we got it down to 88 and
89 respectfully and with that mr speaker
i ask that
fellow members vote no and i request a
roll call vote
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take their
seats
roll call
so
members take their seats
the question before us is the abramson
floor amendment
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
adjutant for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i agree
with my friend from seabrook that
competitive districts are a mechanism
that voters have to enforce term limits
if i know that keeping the seacoast
nashua manchester stratford and
rockingham county together provides the
community of interest representation
better than even the current map so that
congressman and congresswoman can better
serve their constituents
and if i am happy to vote for a map that
doesn't put portsmouth and nashua in the
same cd but makes you have to drive to
mount washington to get from one to the
other
would i now cast this proudly bipartisan
vote by pressing the green button
the chair recognizes
representative lin for a parliamentary
inquiry
excuse me thank you mr speaker
if i know that the comp that the current
districts are not competitive
and that the proposal
made
uh in this uh abramson amendment will
not
make them competitive and if i know as
previously pointed out that there is no
constitutional issue
with the majorities proposed
maps would i then press the red button
and
defeat this proposal
the question before us is the abramson
floor amendment for house bill 52 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you will press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative alicea
representative cannon
representative hawkins phillips
representative le branch
great
sorry
so
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
174 voting yay 182 voting a gaberson
floor amendment fails
we are now down
to the last piece
we're all
bound to ought to pass as
amended the chair recognizes
representative marjorie smith
thank you mr speaker
i rise
uh virtually not in reality
to oppose the pending question
and i thank you mr speaker for ensuring
that
the members of the
new hampshire house are listening
we are an interesting state
it is one of the reasons that we have
been able to maintain the position of a
first in the nation primary
we are about
one-third republican
one-third democratic and one-third
undeclared
we know that the undeclared really
doesn't mean neutral many members of the
undeclared are
favoring one party or the other but that
mix
and the possibility of an open primary
makes us
very
appealing
when
presidentials want to come and
tell us how wonderful they would be if
they could serve in that position
one of the reasons that we have been
able to maintain this position is that
we are in fact a purple state
parts of the state are more red parts
are more blue but all together we are
purple
and we see that
when we realize in the new hampshire
representatives to the u.s congress how
many times
we have changed parties
that is a tribute to all of us in this
state
that we take seriously our
responsibility
in who we vote for and why we are voting
for them
and it means that we as elected
officials
have to pay attention
to what the citizens are telling us
about how they want us to run
their government
that mr speaker is why
i ask this body to oppose the pending
question
the pending question
sets up districts in order to
predetermine
the outcome of the election
and therefore deny
the voters of this state the opportunity
to decide from themselves i believe
that this body is better than that i
believe that this body understands that
we have to respect
the voters in this state and their
desire to be able to say at every two
years whether they want a republican a
democrat or someone else to represent
them
and therefore mr speaker with great
sadness
but with a great degree of commitment i
ask this body to reject
the pending question to vote
itl on or to vote no on the pending
motion
so that we might come back and in fact
present
and
the opportunity
to vote on something that is a tribute
to this body and its respect for the
citizens of the state thank you mr
speaker
representative lynn
thank you mr speaker uh and i apologize
if i'm taking a little longer to speak i
have uh have chronic asthma and it
picked a great time to sort of act up
uh
i rise in support of the majority
amendment
which is now before
before us
we had to change the district because
the population in the state changed and
the po and ex and the changing
population was not equal between the
districts
cd1
gained more population than did cd2
our plan meets constitutional one-man
one-vote requirements as was previously
mentioned the population difference
between cd1 and cd2 under our proposal
is at most 89 individuals out of a total
state population
of almost
1.4
million people
our plan also maintains
contiguity among all towns and cities in
each district
and does not divide any town or city
we've heard much during the committee's
proceedings about gerrymandering
the
dictionary merriam-webster definition of
gerrymander
is and i quote
to divide or arrange a territorial unit
into election districts in a way
to give one political party an unfair
advantage
unfair advantage
so let's see if
if that's what actually happened here
in fact the map created by the majority
does not create
unfair advantages in fact it removes
them
we've heard throughout the proceedings
and i'm sure you've heard on more than
one
occasion
in the newspapers or you've read in the
newspapers you've heard on tv
the phrase quote voters should choose
their reps
not the other way around unquote
i have to admit that's a great talking
point
the only problem is if you actually look
at it
and and scrutinize it for a moment
there's no substance to it
whether directly or indirectly through
some kind of quote-unquote independent
commission
created by legislators
it is always legislators who decide what
districts voters are assigned to
voters never make that choice
many we heard from during our proceed
during the committee's proceedings
asked us to account for
communities of interest
interestingly however
the only community of interest
that they never mentioned that they
wanted us to consider
was political like-mindedness
yet particularly considering that what
we are dividing up our districts for
voting purposes
political affinity would seem to be
among the most important considerations
in this regard i note
that in 2012
our democratic friends recognized that
political similarities did constitute a
community of interest
they then told the supreme court
to define community of interest as quote
a group of people concentrated in a
geographic area who share similar
interests and priorities
whether social
cultural
ethnic economic religious or political
close quote
that's at 163 new hampshire reports page
707.
republicans the the fact is that
republicans and democrats
are not evenly divided throughout our
state
for example
not only politically
but socially and culturally
the portsmouth durham area
has much more in common
with plymouth
keene
hanover and even concord
than it does with manchester salem or
derry
our proposal aligns political
communities
and cultural communities of interest
much better
than does the democratic proposal
also under our plan
manchester the state's largest city
is placed in the same cd
as the many smaller communities
that make up a significant portion
of its commuter workforce
one of the questions that has frequently
been raised and asked both throughout
our proceedings and here is
are the current districts competitive
contrary to claims
to claims
the reality is that neither cd1 nor cd2
but particularly the latter
is competitive
says that the democratic advantage in
cd1
is plus 5.2
and that the democratic
advantage in cd2
is plus 10.4
no one can seriously believe
that a district with a 10.4
percent advantage is competitive
according to mapathon
our proposal actually makes cd1 more
competitive
by changing the district from 5.2
percent plus
for our democratic colleagues to one
point eight percent for republicans
let's talk more fundamentally though
about how important is competitiveness
comp the arguments that we heard during
our proceedings were that
competitiveness forces can competitive
districts forces candidates to the
center
well ask yourself is this really true
given that to win the nomination of
either party
candidates have to appeal to their base
which is usually not in the center
for example
claims that bernie sanders can't win a
national election did not prevent
our new hampshire democratic colleagues
from giving him a victory in our
presidential primary
more importantly
forcing to the center
discourages reforms and new ideas
in a sense
it is analogous to cancel culture
in that it says that debate is permitted
only within a narrow range of
acceptability
as determined by some nebulous standard
established by the media or other elite
forces not accountable to the citizenry
as examples
would ronald reagan or bernie sanders
ever have emerged as real political
forces
under the quote centrist candidates only
formulation
i don't know how many of you in this
room are old enough to remember as i do
when ronald reagan first became
politically prominent
and one and one national office but i
remember clearly
the attacks on him by uh by on mr reagan
president reagan by both democrats and
more centrist republicans
his views on foreign policy will quote
start world war three
and his domestic policies are voodoo
economics
yet those policies brought about the
collapse of the soviet union and one of
our longest periods of sustained
prosperity
so what is the bottom line
our colleagues across the aisle
basically assert that on us on a
statewide basis
our congressional delegation
should produce an allocation that
matches the political breakdown of the
state
they argue in effect
that new hampshire voters
generally
lean about 52 percent voting democrat
and 45 percent voting republican
i'm not sure i agree with that
assessment
nor do i agree with their idea
that a voter whose vote is equally
weighted with that of every other voter
under the one-man one-vote principle
is somehow disenfranchised because of
the way other voters in his or her
district are likely to vote
but for present purposes
let's assume that our democratic
colleagues view is correct
what our friends across the aisle
propose to do
is construct our congressional districts
so that both districts will be democrat
leaning anywhere from roughly 4.5
percent to 10
and what will the result of their
formulation and what will be the result
of their formulation
52 percent of the voters
democrats will get 100 percent of the
congressional seats
they will win both cd1
and cd2
meaning that under their thesis
the 45 percent of the electorate that
tends to vote republican
will be disenfranchised
under the republican proposal by
contrast
which aligns the districts more closely
to the voters leanings
the 52 percent democrat versus 45
republican breakdown
will more likely although by no means
inevitably
yield a 50 50 split one democrat in cd2
and one republican in cd1
thus under our formulation
only two percent of democratic voters
will be disenfranchised
so ask yourself
which is fairer
disenfranchising the 45 percent of
voters who lean republican
or the 2 percent of voters who lean
democratic
the answer
is obvious
for all of these reasons
i ask you to support the majority
proposal the majority amendment and push
the green button i would also move mr
speaker that this debate be put in the
per uh in the permanent journal thank
you mr speaker yeah that that's that's a
separate motion later
i'm sorry thank you
the ques
the question now on is the octopass with
amendment motion
are you ready
roll call i was waiting for that
representative speedy who requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote members
take their seats
[Music]
okay
the question before us
is the ought to pass as amended
on house bill 52
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
expedia for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that our congressional
districts have remained largely
unchanged since they were first
established in the 1880s and i believe
that we have been doing it right the
last 140 years and do not suddenly need
a radical redrawing of our congressional
districts
if i know there were zero granite
theater zero who spoke at our public
input sessions and requested the drastic
unnecessary changes proposed by the
majority and if i know that if i know
gerrymandering when i see it and i know
these districts are reprehensible would
i now press the red button to vote no on
the committee report thank you
the chair
house will be in order
the chair recognizes representative lynn
for a parliamentary inquiry
if i know mr speaker thank you if i know
that the current districts are not
competitive one is more not competitive
than the other but both are really not
competitive and if i know that the
majority's proposal will make at least
one of them competitive not not a walk
for the republican party by any means
but at least competitive
would i then press
the green button
to
support the majority proposal thank you
mr speaker
[Music]
the question is on the ought to pass as
amended motion on house bill 52
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative laflamme
representative langley
representative john mann
representative mason
representable flam are you here
representative leflam sorry could you
please come closer and try using it
you
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend to the state of the vote
186 voting a 164 vote in a the committee
report is adopted
is what reason does the member rise
thank you mr speaker having voted on the
prevailing side i'd like to move
reconsideration on house bill 52 and
urge my colleagues to vote no
the motion is on reconsideration
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
those opposed nay
the nays have it and reconsideration is
defeated
does what member does what reason does a
member rise house will be in order
mr speaker i move that the remarks from
the previous uh debate be printed in the
permanent journal
without objection the remarks will be
printed in the permanent journal
speaker
mr speaker
oh yes representative thank you uh
representative schuett at mike
that's
b-one um
i heard you at the beginning of the
session today
make such an announcement that people
were supposed to identify themselves
and where they were speaking from
and i have noticed several members who
are making unscripted motions
particularly tabling motions
who have not done that
i'm sitting behind a post and it's hard
for me to see
and those who are streaming don't know
who's speaking could you please either
enforce that or announce yourself who
you've recognized to make motions thank
you
the chair recognizes the clerk
thank you mr speaker uh as we get later
in the day a couple of quick reminders
please if you need to leave make sure
that you stop by one of the partisan
tables to get your parking validated
otherwise when you go to leave it'll
cost you six dollars so please make sure
you stop by get your stamps uh on your
tickets uh secondly your voting clickers
we've had a couple that we had to
exchange
so for those members that have had those
exchanged please make sure that you
notate for yourself which ones those are
also
you can deposit them at the the tables
as you're leaving or you can leave them
on your chairs if you're planning to be
here tomorrow thank you very much
representative steven smith
you're up
all right
we have a majority amendment that's got
nothing so you're gonna let that go the
debate is going to be on the minority
amendment
all right
the majority of the committee
on special committee on redistricting to
which was referred house bill 54
an act to portion in county commissioner
districts having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
the majority amendment is 2273
printed on house record 48
on pages 73-74
the minority of the committee on special
committee on redistricting which was
referred house bill 54
uh having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
question before the house is a majority
amendment 2273
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
[Music]
[Applause]
all those opposed nay
you guys have it the amendment's adopted
bill's on second reading and opened a
further amendment
representative weber moves minority
amendment 2276
printed on house record 48 on page
74.
and is recognized to speak to emotion
thank you mr speaker and i am at
microphone b1
so there are 10 counties in the state as
you all know
one county
elects its county commissioners as a
whole county wide
so that didn't change so now we're down
to nine
you will be glad to know that the
committee members agreed
on
the maps for five of the other counties
so we're down to four counties and the
minority amendment addresses those four
counties
they are counties in which the majority
made significant
changes
but the minority majority report says
only that the changes that they made
were constitutional there doesn't seem
to be any
reason for those significant changes
and the minority having looked at the
maps that we have
now have realized that
with no changes or minimum changes
we have achieved
deviations that are far
less significant than the majority
so in carroll county
the majority has a map which goes in
deviation from minus 3.3 to plus 2.6 for
a total of 5.9
the minority with no change to the map
at all
has achieved a deviation of 2.9 roughly
half
of the majority plan
in merrimack county where significant
hinges were made by the majority
the minority moved only one town in
order to balance
the
numbers and that's the only change that
the minority makes from the current maps
in rockingham county
the majority total deviation is 8.2
percent
if you continue the current map
you get a total of deviation of 5.5
percent
and finally in cheshire county
where
the keene area district was kept the
same
but where we now have one easterly
oriented district and one westerly
oriented district
the district was rotated to be a
northern district in a southern district
that was done at a deviation of 7.5
percent
where no change would have kept the
deviation down to 3.7
so if you are dedicated to the person to
the proposition
that every person's vote should count
the same or as close as we can make it
recognizing that it's never going to be
perfect
i would urge you to adopt the minority
amendment 2276
by pressing the green button thank you
mr speaker thank you
the member from epsom representative
mcguire is recognized to speak against
the minority amendment
thank you mr speaker
as
was stated keeps most of the districts
the same
the majority amendment which we have
already adopted
aligns the
county commissioner districts better
with the state rep districts that we
previously adopted
and the
only other significant change was in
merrimack county
where
the majority plan has one town
with the city of concord and the
minority plan has
two towns of the city of concord for the
same population
we think that the
majority maps are more appropriate
and more
excuse me
more appropriate and more representative
and we hope you will support them
thank you the question before the house
is minority committee amendment
2276 are you ready for the question
division votes when called this will be
a division vote members please take your
seats
division
i should do
the question is on the minority
committee amendment 2276
this is a division vote if you're in
favor of the amendment you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button
representative weber is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that there is no reason to align
the congress the
commissioner districts with the state
representative districts because they
deal with completely different issues
and if i know
that this amendment
provides lower deviations and less
disruption to the existing districts
which are working well
would i now press the green button thank
you
thank you
representative mcguire is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
we have adopted the majority amendment
that as as i know that there's no
reasons to change please
vote red
this is a division vote if you're in
favor of the amendment you'll press the
green one a button if you're opposed
you'll press the red to b button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative allegro
representative all chiller
representative berstein
representative baldassaro
representative diesel vestro
representative philadelphi
representative egan
infantine
representative kate murray
representative muse
representative mark pearson
representative petaro
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
157 having voted in the affirmative 182
in the negative the amendment fails
the question now is on the majority
committee report of off to pass as
amended
are you ready for the question
division votes
okey dokey
well look at that
the member from
the member from walpole representative
weber is recognized to speak again it's
okay
perfect
so this is a division vote members
please take your seats
it's like everybody's here
okay
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass as amended
representative piedra is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
i'm sorry
no worries
mr speaker if i know that as amended
this bill significantly
reconfigures districts and counties
where it is not required and if i know
the committee amendment proposes higher
deviation in some counties than
proposals with fewer adjustments
if i know that we can do better and
believe that we should do better would i
now press the red button to vote no to
reject the committee report thank you
thank you
member from barrington representative
sherkots recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that hb 54 as amended meets
all constitutional
and unanimously imposed committee
requirements
would i now support the majority of the
special committee on redistricting's
commissioner map
by pressing the green button
thank you this is a division vote
if you are in favor you'll be pressing
the green button if you're opposed
you'll be pressing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
away
representative ames okay got it
representative infant if you could just
move a little closer it'll probably pick
it up
representative cannon
it looks like you're walking towards us
holding a fazer
so
representative
mackey representative lockman
representative mcbride
representative michelier
is representative packard in the room
mr speaker you're in the room please
vote
thank you
representative
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
184 having voted in the affirmative 159
in the negative the committee report is
adopted mr speaker
for what reason does the member rise
having voted in the affirmative on hb 54
i move reconsideration and urge a no or
red vote
representative duchette moves
reconsideration on hb 54 are you ready
for the question
all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
all those opposed nay
the motion fails
mr speaker
can i move to uh print the remarks from
the last debate into the permanent
journal without objection
nice
the committee on commerce and consumer
affairs to which was referred house bill
an act establishing a committee to study
the benefits of allowing new hampshire
citizens to purchase health insurance
from out-of-state companies
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill we referred for interim study the
questions on the committee report of
interim study are you ready for the
question for the chair
state your inquiry um
this is a
a parliamentary inquiry which is
the bill that we're voting on is a study
committee bill which has been referred
to interim study which is um
not entirely unprecedented but pretty
rare so what
what will the
interim study committee be allowed to
study will they merely be studying the
narrow question of whether there should
have been a study committee in the first
place or will they be able to
look at the underlying issue
i would imagine during interim study
they would consider and answer all those
questions thank you for your income okay
thank you mr chair that's mr jim mr
speaker
i hear you but i don't see it
who's up now
ah there you are mr speaker yes i was
standing here waiting before but then
you went real quick into the next build
i was trying to get a motion in on the
print the last bill
um hb 52 into the journal
already done
already done okay i missed it thank you
mr speaker you're welcome
back to the bill at hand
the question is on the committee report
of interim study are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the majority of the committee on
commerce and consumer affairs to which
was referred house bill 592 fn an act
requiring bond from pharmaceutical
companies providing vaccines having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative greeson for the majority
of the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative christie
bartlett for the minority of the
committee
all right
yeah
yep
the member from seabrook representative
abramson is recognized to speak in
support of the committee report
uh thank you mr speaker i rise in favor
of the motion for interim study on house
bill 592 bonds for vaccines
uh we found during the uh the hearing
only six percent of those suffering from
vax
from vaccine injuries
mostly children resulted in compensation
from the federal vaccine fund
and only after many years of costly
litigation
children suffering brain damage autism
and other medical complications need
medical help now so the republicans on
commerce felt that some solution needed
to be found to help these families
sooner
so for that reason i'm asking members to
press the green button and support the
majority on commerce
thank you the member from concord
representative bartlett is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i'm over here on
1a
i rise before you to speak against the
recommendation to refer for interim
study
there are many flaws in this bill that
no amount of amending it could could fix
first the sponsor admitted that he
didn't understand what a bond is in its
purpose
next a billion dollar bond is not
obtainable in any market for this
purpose
third we know that vaccines have
prevented terrible diseases such as
smallpox measles and polio these are
diseases of the past
this bill may be aiming at the current
pandemic but the unintended consequences
of this type of broad sweep for any
vaccine is so very dangerous
why would the new hampshire legislature
want to make it more difficult for
pharmaceutical companies to distribute
vaccines
i'm not up here to defend the profits of
the large pharmaceutical companies but i
don't believe that setting up another
state agency or fund is a viable
answer administering such a program fund
to compensate anyone who might want to
make a claim
preempting the national vaccine
compensation program
would also be a huge hurdle to overcome
there's no money in the budget for such
a program nor is there consideration for
how the dhhs
could possibly respond
there's no mechanism in the bill for
determining a medical condition from a
vaccine reaction
would you just tell your doctor that
you're not feeling well from your
vaccine and the state would give you
money
nor is there any provision for
determining a fraudulent claim
nor which state agency would be
responsible for investigating
how would dhhs know how to investigate
such a claim
can i can i ask the members to spend for
a moment
it's a bit noisy in here and the member
has a right to be heard so let's give
her that right i apologize
representative please continue thank you
mr
speaker bill requires a turnaround time
of 15 days
from the date of receipt of a claim to
payment it's completely unreasonable
without due process
the bill is trying to set up a pool of
money from which money people can draw
from without oversight and without the
structure that would be necessary to
make this a meaningful program
during the public hearing many spoke in
opposition with pointed questions to
which there were no answers
no other states are concurrently
considering such an action
please vote down the motion so another
motion can be brought forward thank you
thank you the member from wentworth
representative greeson is recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker and members of the
house house bill 592 is intended to
provide new hampshire residents with
protection against injury caused by
vaccinations
now nothing about this bill
or its sponsor and supporters should be
slandered with the pejorative of
anti-vaxx
this bill is not covet-centric although
it does apply to covid
now advancements in medicine have
resulted in vaccines being developed
that have helped minimize the effects
and spread of some of the deadliest
viruses ever to plague the planet so
there is value to vaccines no one is
denying that but as with every medicine
or vaccine there are potential risks
no vaccine or medicine is 100 percent
effective and some people will
experience significant side effects even
death
the national institutes for health state
that more than 1.5 million people are
hospitalized every year because of quote
adverse drug reactions unquote meaning
side effects from medications
and approximately one hundred thousand
patients die from drugs uh drug side
effects
however according to forty two u s codes
subsection three hundred no vaccine
manufacturer shall be liable in a civil
action for damages arising from a
vaccine-related injury or death
associated with the administration of a
vaccine after october 1 1988. if the
injury or death resulted from side
effects that were unavoidable even
though the vaccine was properly prepared
and was accompanied by proper directions
and warnings
the national vaccine injury compensation
program was subsequently developed to
handle vaccine injury claims because
vaccine injuries do happen in fact over
4.7 billion dollars has been paid out
covering 8594
compensable vaccine entry claims since
the program began in eighty eight but
that's eight thousand five hundred
ninety four claims paid out of twenty
four thousand six hundred ninety six
petitions filed or just thirty five
percent
funding for the national vaccine injury
compensation program comes from a 75
cent dose per uh per dose tax on every
dose of vaccine administered for every
disease being vaccinated against so that
means that mmr measles mumps and rubella
would have 2.25 tax applied because it
covers 75 cents for measles 75 cents for
mumps and 75 cents for rubella
the national vaccine injury compensation
program only covers
childhood vaccines and seasonal flu
shots
but it was only in 2006 that the flu
shot started being covered and adults
injured by a flu shot could also file a
petition
and since 2006 5 351 claims have been
paid out of 23 619 petitions filed for
injuries due to flu shots
this means since the program's inception
over 60 percent of all paid claims have
been since 2006 and were for adults
injured as a result of receiving flu
shots
now the national vaccine injury
compensation does not a program does not
cover all vaccines
it does not cover shingles pneumococcal
pneumonia off-season flu shots and
several others
and because the national vaccine injury
compensation program does not cover all
vaccines people may be injured by a
vaccine and have no recourse whatsoever
and it should be noted that the national
vaccine injury compensation program does
not cover the kovid shot
and this is where house goal 592 becomes
important one house bill 592
could be amended to apply all vacci
apply to all vaccines authorized for use
under the emergency use
authorization including those for covid
it could be amended to
compensate new hampshire residents
injured by a vaccine not covered by the
national vaccine injury compensation
program
following discussions with multiple
vaccine injury attorneys it was
determined that house bill 592 would be
a beneficial program if it were amended
to cover only vaccines not covered by
the national program because when
someone files a petition with the
national program they must declare
whether or not they've already received
any compensation for their injury
any compensation under house bill 592
could and would most likely interfere
with the national program and that is an
undesired consequence
additionally concerns arose during work
sessions regarding the funding mechanism
for this program a better funding
mechanism would be needed than a bond
such as a per dose fee
insulting the intelligence of the
sponsor of the bill does not solve
anything
given that there are still some details
that need work but the overall validity
and usefulness of this bill remains the
majority of the commerce committee has
agreed to refer house bill 592 for
interim study to determine how best to
proceed and i hope everyone will agree
with the majority and allow house bill
592 to go to interim study and have the
details worked out because vaccine
injuries can occur to anyone regardless
of party affiliation thank you
thank you
the questions on the majority report of
referred for interim studies somebody
requested a division vote so this will
be a division vote
representative bert request a roll call
shocker is that sufficiently seconded
i don't think it's sufficiently seconded
this will be a division vote
they were already standing there
yeah they'll have to wave next time
they're already standing there so i can
tell they were standing the second
division
[Music]
mr speaker
yes
i counted at least 14.
we didn't
sorry
i have glasses it's a division vote
all right
mr speaker
already offered not sufficiently
seconded this is we're in the voting
mode members have taken their seats now
okay
representative burroughs is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that a one billion dollar bond is not
obtainable in any market for the purpose
of compensating anyone who might want to
seek reimbursement or payment of the
costs related to illness and death due
to a vaccine
and if i know that there is no money in
the state budget for such a program nor
is there consideration as to how dhs
dhhs
will administer such a program and if i
know that this bill attempts to create a
pool of money to administer such a
program without any oversight and
without any specific structure would i
now push the red button to vote against
the committee recommendation to refer
for interim study
thank you mr speaker thank you
representative greeson's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that a bill has validity but still
has some details that could be hashed
out if given the opportunity through an
interim study
would i press the green button to allow
that bill to be referred to
for interim study thank you
thank you the questions on the majority
committee reported referred for interim
study this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative alexander thank you
representative allegro
representative mackey
who the hell is that representative
wayne mcdonald
representative lockman
representative nutting wong
representative snow
representative thompson
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
168 having voted in the affirmative 167
and the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
commerce and consumer affairs to which
was referred senate bill 68 an act
requiring an employer to provide
reasonable accommodations for pregnant
employees having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study
representative greeson for the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative bartlett for the
minority of the committee
the member from concord representative
bartlett is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
colleagues i come before you to speak
against the soft death also known as
interim study
this bill has been heard before the
house and senate in the past and both
times passed by voice vote but lost in
the omnibus bill of 2020.
the bill simply requires an employer to
provide reasonable accommodations
to an employee related to the employee's
pregnancy or childbirth
there are provisions in different parts
of existing law
but this bill would consolidate
non-discrimination for pregnancy-caused
issues into one location in the statute
statistics show that we're in a time of
new businesses and more entrepreneurship
there will be new employees new
pregnancies
and new work situations
there is a hardship clause included for
any employer that can demonstrate that
the accommodation would impose an undue
hardship
on the operation of the employer's
business
at a time when businesses are
desperately trying to find employees why
would the new hampshire legislature want
to make it more difficult for a pregnant
woman in the workplace
since 2016 there have been four public
employer charges and 74
private employer charges filed
the new hampshire commission for human
rights exists to enforce the law against
discrimination in employment
they can provide volunteer mediators at
no cost to the parties to mitigate
disputes
the commission does not provide legal
advice nor do they want to take sides
even with positive outcomes from the
mediations
having a statute that applies to
discrimination
for pregnancy related issues in one
place that is clear concise and easy to
find should be the aim for any law
shouldn't it
it's helpful for any employer looking to
comply too
for those of us who have been pregnant
there are some inconveniences about this
temporary condition
most employers want to do the right
thing and may just need some guidance
the commission is not there with a
sledgehammer and we know they're not
looking to go to court for unnecessary
reasons
clarifying the discrimination statute is
a win-win for all sides the employee
the employer and the public
please note there were 91 who signed in
support of this bill and only five in
opposition
please vote against the motions so that
another motion can be brought forward
thank you
thank you the member firm rep wentworth
representative greeson has recognized
speak in support of the committee report
yeah thank you mr speaker and members of
the house during testimony on sb 68 the
executive director of the human rights
commission
including other uh
others plus other members of the house
repeatedly testified that all this bill
would do is copy portions of current
laws as written in different rsas and
place them in one location however
despite testimony saying this law would
not actually change anything
all references to the new location and
statute would put this bill under
workers compensation laws all references
were the workers compensation laws and
it would introduce changes making
pregnancy a compensable disability now
i'm not sure how one gets pregnant at
work but that's a different issue
due to the potential conflict the
majority of the commerce committee
recommends sb 68 be referred for interim
study in order to best define what needs
to be done
who needs to do it and where in statute
it needs to be placed thank you
thank you the question is on the
majority committee report of referred
for interim study are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say
aye all those opposed nay
[Applause]
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
representative ducette can you please
come up here
there he is
representative doucette
uh
um
all right
here we go
while they're working that out the
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs which was referred
senate bill 69 fn an act requiring
employers to provide access to a
sufficient space for nursing mothers and
reasonable break time having considered
the same report the same with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
johnson for the committee the amendment
is two one seven five h printed on house
record 48 on pages 108-109 the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative bartlett for the minority
of the committee
the chair recognizes representative hunt
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
really want to get commerce over right
now
and just found out that there's some
information about this bill that it's
probably an unfunded representative
okay
delay
senate bill 69 on the table
representative hunt moves that senate
bill 69 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
a division vote's been requested this
will be a division vote question of the
presiding officer parliamentary inquiry
at uh
e1
what division
what's your parliamentarian correct uh
my parliamentary inquiry is an actual
parliamentary inquiry if this bill is
laid on the table uh when is the
opportunity to take it off the table
could it be taken off the table
theoretically tomorrow or is there a
time limit
you can come off the table anytime
yeah and
bills have come off the table the
deadline you want to look at is in this
case last day to act on senate bills
so before that you can still do
something with it all right thank you
very much
so the question before the house is
whether to table senate bill 69 this is
a division vote members should be in
their seats
yep
representative weston's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that in these times of short
labor to
supply we need to respect the needs of
every worker including new mothers to
keep them in the workforce
and if i know that babies flourish on
their mother's milk during their first
year of life
and everyone in new hampshire wants
healthy babies
and if i know that tabling this bill
will deny this house the opportunity to
discuss the merits of the bill
then would i not push the red button to
defeat the tabling motion
thank you representative rice is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that sb 69 is an unfunded
mandate on municipalities and schools
would i now vote green to table sb69
thank you mr speaker
thank you
the question is whether to lay sent bill
69 on the table this is a division vote
if you're in favor of laying it on the
table you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative baruti are you still here
representative cats of course
representative mackey i think he left
representative bill nelson
representative vincent
representative testerman
of all members president i had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
180 having voted in the affirmative 155
in the negative senate bill 69 is laid
on the table
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 147 fn and
acts relative to assault against an
elderly person having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative terry roy for the
majority of the committee the committee
amendment is 2 2 0 0 printed in house
record 48 on pages 83 to 84.
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
chris true for the minority of the
committee
the question is on the
committee amendment 2200h
are you ready for the question
division votes been requested this will
be a division vote members please take
your seats
representative burt has referee asked
for a roll call and it is sufficiently
seconded
this will be a roll call vote
you still have to take receipts
[Music]
hmm
um
all right
the question is on the committee
amendment choo choo zero zero
mr speaker can i do api this will be a
roll call vote if you're in favor of the
amendment you'll be pressing the green
button i guess if you're opposed you'll
be pressing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
brad
representative all chiller
representative aaron representative
blasic
representative baldassaro representative
bunker representative burroughs
representative chase
representative elliott
representative frost
representative gotling representative
gay
representative grota representative ham
representative herbert
representative levitt
representative laflamme
representative lockman representative
love
representative maggie representative
maggiore
representative bill nelson
representative porter representative
clausier representative perez
representative peterson representative
rice
representative query
representative snow
representative timothy smith
representative denise smith
representative testerman representative
vincent representative thompson
representative von plinsky
representative vail
well then
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
66 having voted in the affirmative 260
and the negative the amendment fails
question is now on ought to pass on
house bill
mr speaker
representative is at d1 i'd like to make
a motion
representative abbas moves that house
bill 147 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
[Music]
okay house bill 147 is late on the table
that's a good time for
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 238
an act prohibiting provocations based on
a victim's actual or perceived gender
gender identity
gender expression or sexual orientation
from being used as a defense in
manslaughter cases having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative conley for the
majority of the committee mr speaker
mayor b1
um
we had a point of order
yeah we're on uh 238 but we have 237 on
the calendar
to quote a good friend and colleague go
check what they give me
thank you thank you
got it
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 237 fna
an act relative to the legalization and
regulation of cannabis and making
appropriations therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative kevin pratt for the
majority of the committee
the major the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative cainley
casey conley for the minority of the
committee
the member from dover representative
conley is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i do rise today against the
interim study recommendation for hb 237
it's it's getting pretty noisy in here
i'm right here and i'm having trouble
hearing them
remember i was alright to be heard
thank you mr speaker
uh so as i was saying a nearly identical
version of this bill came before this
very house two years ago
it passed this house with strong
bipartisan support
this is not a bill that needs more study
this bill would create a mechanism to
legalize regulate and tax recreational
cannabis for adults 21 and older it sets
reasonable limits
for the possession of cannabis and
cannabis products that are consistent
with personal use
it supports private enterprise and it
creates a framework to determine who
could sell this product where these
stores could be located and how these
businesses would be regulated
it establishes a framework for how
cannabis revenue would be allocated
the estimated 40 million dollars a year
in new revenue would pay for substance
misuse programs it would go to the
general fund and it would help offset
local property taxes
finally this bill restricts advertising
of cannabis and cannabis related
products it's a complex bill it takes up
nearly 30 pages
but it's a finely detailed bill to
govern how a legalization structure
would work in the state
the framework contained in this did not
emerge out of thin air in fact the bill
before you incorporates key
recommendations from the state's own
cannabis study commission which offered
a road map and best practices for how to
legalize and regulate cannabis for adult
use
those best practices and that road map
are the core of this bill
everyone in this room is aware that new
hampshire is an island of cannabis
prohibition
cannabis is now legal in 18 states blue
states red states purple states
the sky has not fallen in these places
new hampshire residents want cannabis to
be legal here too we know that because
they've told us they want it to be legal
here
the most recent unh poll showed support
for legalization has grown to 78
78 of our residents want this to pass
so with that i ask you again please
reject the interim study recommendation
so that another more appropriate motion
can be made and mr speaker asks for a
division vote
thank you
the member from salem representative
abbas is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
just to clarify what this bill would
actually do we would create
two new taxes including a sales tax
which completely con contradicts the new
hampshire advantage it also would create
a transfer tax which is
kind of similar to a sales tax if you
ask me
so anyone who took that pledge to not
support any new taxes you would be
violating that pledge remember suspend
for a sec i know it's awkward but
they'll hear you better if you speak
right into it
thank you mr speaker
oh that is much better
in addition to that there are several
bills that have been filed relating to
recreational canvas that my colleague
who just spoke actually co-sponsored
with me
that the
criminal justice public safety committee
has yet to have a public hearing on and
i believe that those bills have a are
much more rounded and don't have any new
taxes but those haven't obviously been
considered yet uh considering what this
bill would actually do
is create a lot of
a large expansion of government that is
not supported by any revenue stream that
is sustainable to actually fund that and
that is an unknown unknown in the fiscal
note
given given that consideration
and given that there's a lot of uh reg
over regulation of a product
and when i say over regulation you
couldn't put the you would legalize a
product but you wouldn't be allowed to
put the plant in your window
you're only allowed to have you're gonna
have a private enterprise that can only
sell one ounce of its product at a time
yet that is the only product that they
sell
that is a recipe for disaster and
there's been nothing presented to our
committee to suggest that that type of
business model that is over regulated
like that
is sustainable
for that therefore i ask that we support
the committee recommendation interim
study so we can we can consider the
other bills that we have yet to have a
public hearing on thank you mr speaker
thank you a division vote was requested
on
this it will be a division vote members
please take your seats
i have mexicans
i feel bad i can't even get a name right
so
we all in
all right
the question before the house is the
majority
committee report of referred for interim
study
representative abramson is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that nearly 80 percent of the people
in
new hampshire now support
re-legalization of marijuana if i
understand that more and more people
conservative liberal moderate
libertarian independent want to have to
get the drug problem to pay for itself
and mr speaker
if i don't believe in taxation at all if
i believe the taxation of wages is
slavery but i still understand that this
is much much much better than literally
putting people in prison and turning
them into de facto slaves in reality
would i press the red button so that
another motion can be made
thank you representative abbas is
recognized for parliamentary for
thank you mr speaker if i know
that hb 237 would create a sales tax and
if i know mr speaker that while taxation
is theft would i then go ahead and push
that green button
we're already in in the middle of the
vote
the question is on the majority
committee report of referred for interim
study this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
represent
representative abrami representative de
shays
got you all set representative
representative soti
representative testerman
representative vale you're good
representative tripp
you're all set representative duchess
representative herbert
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
i also attend to the state of the vote
158 having voted in the affirmative
171 and the negative
the committee report fails
mr speaker
ought to pass on hb 237
representative conley moves ought to
pass on house bill 237 are you ready for
the question
division votes been requested this will
be a division vote
representative harrington requests a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
[Music]
mr speaker
mr speaker one moment please
for what reason does the member rise
i was i know we're in the voting road
but i was wondering if i could make a
motion to table
yeah we've already put the question so
okay thank you
all right
the question is on the motion about to
pass on house bill 237
uh mr speaker what reason does a member
rise uh point of order um i moved
uh by email move out to pass on hb 237
if the
uh is motion fails and pi if no one
else signs up
requested to speak on this if we already
have piage
what's that we we already have ps
okay
all right i i asked to speak in the
email okay
representative abbas is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that a
bill that i am the prime sponsor of
would allow recreational cannabis but
not have a sales tax
and mr speaker if i know
that hb 237 actually has a sales tax and
a transfer tax
and and mr speaker alaska i know that
this bill
is it would likely be assigned to
another committee and the non-sales tax
bill would probably be
voted on in our committee a criminal
justice public safety committee
before this bill is voted on again by
the house
should i go ahead and push that red
button and oppose the motion about to
pass
thank you mr speaker thank you
representative egan is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker if i know that a 2019 unh
survey said stated that 78 of new
hampshire residents supporting
legalizing cannabis and 80 would support
cannabis being sold and licensed at
retail outlets then should we act on
what the people of new hampshire want
and mr speaker if i know that the street
three states surrounding new hampshire
have legal cannabis businesses creating
and will create as up to
two billion dollars to a state directly
below us then new hampshire is losing
out on new revenue that could help fund
key issues in the state like public
education and mental health care without
raising property taxes and lastly mr
speaker if i believe that a further
that an ought to pass
on this bill will allow new hampshire to
have learned from the best practices and
the worst practices of the other states
in new england regarding legalized
cannabis and we now know how to move
forward with logical and sustainable
legalized cannabis for new hampshire
residents but i now vote yes on ought to
pass and push the green button thank you
mr speaker
thank you the question is on the motion
of off to pass on house bill 237
if you are in favor you'll be pressing
the red button if you're opposed you'll
be pressing the green button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
what's going on
if you're in favor of about to pass
you'll be pressing the green button if
you're opposed you'll be pressing the
red button
representative levesque
representative
levitt representative mcbride
representative tripp
representative soti
good
representative levitt is that you back
there that i see can you come down
because you're not registering
so
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
163 having voted in the affirmative 170
in the negative
the motion fails representative mr
speaker abbas is recognized for a motion
mr speaker can i make a motion to table
yes you may
representative abbas moves at house bill
237 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
division votes been requested members
please take your seats again
division
so
the question is whether to lay house
bill 237 on the table
mr speaker there we go point of order
state your point of order
oh never mind it just changed
the
screen wasn't matching the vote
all right
that's the division vote
are there pis
okay mr speaker point of order
back here on e1 state your point of
order
correct me if i'm wrong i'm sure i am
didn't we just defeat 237
no
we voted down a motion
okay so octopass was proposed ought to
pass failed
that's the parliamentary state right now
so the motion before the house is
whether to lay house bill 237 on the
table
if you are in favor of laying it on the
table you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative levitt
could you please come back down
representative ammon
representative bailey representative
allegro
representative tucker
representative stavis
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
300 having voted in the affirmative 32
and the negative
mr speakers bill 237 is laid on the
table mr speaker
what reason does it memorize
d1
um mr speaker i'd like to make a motion
state your motion
i'd like to special order house bill 607
to the next order of business
representative ammon moves that house
bill 607 be ordered to the
next order of business
representative shirtless asks for a
division vote
representative amman would you like to
speak to your motion
representative ammon
would you like to speak to your motion
yes i would
all right god
we heard similar uh things earlier when
we special ordered the redistricting
bills
there's issues of weather and people's
health and i think the attendance in
this room represents
uh as a good representation of the will
of the people so
and another reason is uh i thought we'd
get to education today but we spent so
much time on other bills that we it so
let's hear the debate about house bill
and please vote green on special order
the house will be in order
representative sherlock is recognized to
speak against motion
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
i would ask my friends in the house to
please vote against the
motion to special audit this bill
house bill 607
we are now within 25 minutes of the time
that the speaker has told us that we'd
be recessing at six o'clock
i know it's a long day and many people
in the chamber are getting tied
including myself
um
mr speaker also we've got eight people
signed up to speak on this bill
this this house
we maybe did not make as much progress
as we would like to
but everyone has been attentive and
taking part in all the votes it has been
a very long day
and lastly mr speaker i'd say to you
that i know there are some
municipalities that have city meetings
tonight the city of nashua and other
communities where members want to get to
those meetings and we have members that
have left who did want to take part in
this
this debate in this vote on house bill
607 so it asks the body to vote no thank
you
thank you
representative sherlock requested a
division vote members please take your
seats
[Music]
so
the question before the house is whether
to special order house bill 607 to the
next order of business
representative sherlock was recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know mr
speaker that the house was told that we
would recess at 6 00 p.m
which is only 20 minutes from now
and if i know mr speaker we've got eight
people signed up to debate this bill
and if i know mr speaker that it's been
a long day we're all tired and some of
our members have already left for the
day because of this weather
and lastly mr speaker as i mentioned
earlier there are some community
meetings tonight that our members want
to get to would i now push the red
button and vote no thank you mr speaker
thank you
representative amman's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know our side of the
aisle is not tired and that we're here
to do uh the business of the people and
if i know that this
is a good representation based on
uh the procedures earlier today
and uh that we want to hear this
important bill this bill is going to go
to a second committee
we have a lot of questions about this
bill in our communities let's hear the
debate tonight and uh if if i know that
would i push the green button
the question is whether to reorder house
bill 607
special order house bill 607 unless the
order of business this is division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative dilorenzo
representative gallagher representative
gamarlo
representative lockman
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
161 having voted in the affirmative 172
and the negative the motion fails
house will be in order
[Applause]
sure
oh
chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne for the
third reading motion
i resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
the third reading be read a third time
by this resolution and that all titles
of bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it'd be to
meet thursday january 6th 2022 at 9 00
a.m
question is on the third reading motion
are ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the third reading
motion is adopted
including your
memorial remarks so please be quiet okay
we have
we have no announcements i have won
uh i've been told that the attendants
are at the exit gates ready to take your
tickets
we do have
two
three inanna's making sense
two are memorial
so i would ask that everybody please be
attentive
uh the chair recognizes representative
long
these are memorial remarks
thank you mr speaker
and i ask that manchester uh delegates
want to want to rise
mr speaker i rise in memorial and
reflection of our colleague
representative barbara shaw
representative shaw led a life of
community service throughout her entire
life
she served children teaching for 35
years and after retirement she served
for many more years as an assistant
principal and substitute teacher
representative shaw served 22 years in
this house in 14 years as an alderman in
manchester
i would often have conversation with
representative char and learn quickly
over respect and appreciation
for the people she served her compassion
and ability and service to her
constituents remarkably shined brightly
representative shaw has a unique ability
in taking her constituents by the hand
and showing them a way into a better
quality of life
she wouldn't direct them she would walk
with them
at 79 years old she was delivering
struggling constituents to work
spent the weekend packing an elder woman
who was unable to do so on her own
to move out of her apartment
and spent precious time with a
terminally ill former student bringing
him to the state house in automatic
meetings showing him how special he was
and how grateful she was of his health
to her work will the member will
remember
will people please have with respect for
the memorial remarks
you may continue thank you mr speaker
representative shaw gload of honesty and
karen for all those who happen to cross
her path
i recall setting up a meeting for
manchester and calling representative
shaw to see and
see if the day and time would fit her
schedule
she told me she wants to attend the
meeting but at that time she goes to
church with her sister
i told her i can accommodate her under
one condition
that
when you go to church can you pray for
me
i could steal her unique voice i could
still hear her unique voice clearly in
my head saying
do you really think that's going to help
you
as i reflected this past week my heart
would often hurt over the loss
i would be experiencing i thought of
whom would suffer the greatest loss her
family especially her grandchildren whom
she would consistently watch and if had
the luxury
if you had the luxury of having a
conversation with her you knew what they
looked like and what their individual
characters were like
for constituents it's not often that you
would see an elected official selflessly
walk with their troubled constituent
toward a better quality of life
representative shaw always found the
personal time in working to bring
solutions to all the fortunate people
she served
students throughout her life she was
compelled in bringing opportunity to
young people that needed the extra
mentoring and academic achievement i
knew of her after school work at
manchester's elmwood garden a low income
in new american neighborhood
last week i received a call from another
nashua over work with students there
also
representative barbara shaw thank you
for touching our lives and the lives of
so many people in new hampshire
i know in my heart where you are today
do you think you could put in a good
word for us in the legislature
representative barbara shaw may your
well-deserved rest be in peace thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker d2
d2
d1 yes
mr speaker i would ask that the remarks
by the distinguished gentleman from
manchester be entered into the public
record
without objection
representative mooney
thank you i'm at d2
mr speaker and members of the house
i rise to recognize three
distinguished former state
representatives from merrimack who
earned their eternal rewards last year
they are the honorable jack balcom
the honorable nancy elliott
and the honorable tony pellegrino
jack balcom was a proud graduate of the
united states naval academy
then enlisted in the united states
marine corps
he was dedicated to public service
having served three terms in the new
hampshire house
including that as vice chair of
education
he spent countless hours devoted to
civic and charitable organizations
young students and committees in town
including service as a water
commissioner and as trustee of the trust
funds
nancy elliott served three terms in the
house on the judiciary committee
she was known for her kind demeanor good
humor
and passionate advocacy for the
vulnerable disabled and elderly
after the legislature she traveled the
world
speaking and testifying on behalf of the
euthanasia prevention coalition
tony pellegrino served five terms in the
new hampshire house
including that as vice chair of the
labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
committee
additionally he held various leadership
positions in town such as selectmen
the civil defense director for merrimack
and as a water commissioner
the entire merrimack delegation is truly
blessed to have known and worked with
jack
nancy
and tony
the merrimack community is fortunate to
have benefited from their years of
dedicated service
they will be dearly missed and we
respectfully ask that you
remember them
and their families
in your thoughts and prayers
thank you
[Applause]
we all have a
moment of silence for our
deceased colleagues
who many of us knew
mr speaker
may i please ask that the comments of
representative mooney be entered into
the permanent record without objection
representative perez
thank you mr speaker
for let me speak up i would ask for a
minute of silence for
the 13 lies that we lost in philadelphia
today during our session it was a big
fire in philadelphia
and we still
counting how many more lives they're
gonna come from
we're gonna lose from that fire so i
would like to take a
minute of silence for those people who
lost their life including three children
thank you mr speaker
the house is in recess until thursday
oh
representative osborne moves at the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
the introduction of bills enrolled
billed amendments and enrolled bill
reports receiving messages are you ready
for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
tim lang for a very quick announcement
uh one quick announcement from
representative lange
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i just
want to invite the entire house over to
bella vans brewery the owner has agreed
to open his establishment to everybody
give them a walking tour and this
includes with staff if they want to come
over do a walking tour and provide some
food as well so against bella vance
brewery on
petting gill road and here in
londonderry thank you
the house is in recess until thursday
january 6 2022 at 9 00 a.m
okay
you